- Is it hard to make friends
when you were like a transfer student?
- I think it's impossible to make friends.
- This is such a lie, anime
would have you believe
that transfer student-
- Yeah, they're like all over-
- Everyone wants to know
the transfer student.
- Big surprise here,
and I'm gonna give you
a huge reality check,
but as an anime singer,
anime is not exactly real.
(laughs)
- No!
- Hello and welcome to another
episode of Trash Taste.
I am your host for today,
Garnt, and joining me
as usual are the boys.
And once again, I am
hosting another guest.
- No.
- Do you wanna introduce yourself
and tell us what you do?
Or tell the viewers what
you do, I should say.
- Sure, hi, my name is nano.
You probably don't know who I am,
but nice to meet you,
nice to meet you guys.
- Very humble start.
- I have to say, you were the only reason
why I loved "BTOOOM!" so much.
- Oh, really?
Wow.
- "BTOOOM!" Opening
is so God damn good.
- That's amazing.
- I'm just gonna get
that out of the way.
- That you know my song.
- Of course, who doesn't know your song?
- Oh, really?
- Yeah, honestly,
from like, especially "BTOOOM!,"
but out of everything about "BTOOOM!,"
I still remember the opening.
- Yeah, to this day.
- Wow.
- And it's impressive,
because I don't remember
a lot about that show.
It's been many, it's
been many, many years.
But I still, the opening
just fuckin' bangin'.
I just got to say that right now.
- And also, "Arpeggio
of Blue Steel" opening
is like so freaking good.
- Okay, I do remember
that show being quite bad.
But, but the opening though, you know-
- Yeah, opening's bangin'.
- Really?
- Even though I'm often mocked
because I can't really appreciate music,
but I have to admit, your music,
I like the noise.
- Thank you.
That is an honor to hear,
that is an honor to hear.
- Beats on the boots.
- So do you wanna
introduce yourself a little
to the viewers so they can
learn a bit more about you?
- Well, you know, as they said,
I sang a couple openings for anime series.
- Anime series.
I'm losing my words here,
because talking is not my job.
So, you know.
- I mean, yeah, you sing.
- I sing, I sing.
- You have a much more
lovely voice than we do.
We just talk shit all
day, and that's our job.
- But, you know, today is my
sort of YouTube debut day.
- Oh wow, oh, you're debuting today.
- Yeah, so maybe I'm gonna
be a YouTuber from now on.
- I did see you did a YouTube
live stream at one point.
- I did, I did.
I would love to do more stuff on YouTube.
So this today is sort of my challenge day,
and I'm really looking
forward to sort of uncovering
a new sort of me-
- A new side of yourself.
- A new nano, a new nano.
- Exciting new adventure.
- The amount of pressure
she just dropped all over us-
- That sounds like good,
exciting new adventure.
That's gonna be my new song lyric.
- Oh, wow.
- Well done.
- But yeah, 'cause I was curious,
obviously, you've done anime openings
and you do your own original music,
but how did you get your start in that?
- Oh, that's a really long,
so you really don't wanna go there?
- Yeah, sure.
- We got the time.
- We got the time, let's
jump right into it.
- I thought about looking
at the Wikipedia page
and research-
- Oh no, no, don't go there.
Don't go there, don't go there.
- I wanna be like the viewer
and experience everything about it.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Oh, that's great, though.
- So tell us everything.
- Don't, don't go to Wiki.
Get your information from the real source.
- Firsthand.
- Yes.
Well, I started off, well,
I've always wanted to become
a singer since I was little,
but I started off
actually on the internet.
So I was an internet singer.
I did a lot of YouTube, right,
that goes back way back to history.
Even before all this like
YouTube boom happened,
I was a YouTuber, so-
- What year,
what year, what year?
I got to ask.
- Oh, what year?
Way back when, it's like 2000, like-
- Like when you have
to favorite the videos
and give five stars it.
- Yes, and like, no matter what you did,
you never got money for it, you know.
- So back when it was a
four-by-three aspect ratio.
Oh, OG YouTuber, brilliant.
- Is that when you started, Garnt?
- I mean, I started at kind
of the beginning of YouTube,
so-
- You started like 2006,
right?
- 2007.
So YouTube launched in
2006 and I made my first-
- Yeah, it was late 2000s.
So I was, you know, just on YouTube,
I did my own original
songs, uploaded videos.
And then I started, you know,
Japan started getting
into the sort of movie,
internet-
- Into like the culture of it.
- So you're full Japanese, half Japanese?
- I'm full Japanese, I was
born and raised in America.
My parents are both Japanese.
So I'm kind of a hybrid.
- So bilingual as well-
- Bilingual,
but I'd say I'm like, my roots are,
the stronger roots are America.
So I still find a lot of Japanese things
really like crazy insane, fucked up.
- I mean, we've talked
about the weird things
we find about Japanese
culture all the time.
I'm sure we'll get into it.
- I saw that video
this morning.
I watched before coming
here, so I'm good to go.
I spent two hours.
- She did her research.
- She's probably did
more research than us.
I feel bad now.
- Well, I mean, I, 'cause like,
Connor's the kind of person who's like,
I don't read the Wikipedia,
I'd rather just hear it from the person.
But like, I thought I would just dive
slightly into the Wikipedia
and kind of ask you-
- That's the research
benchmark, I read the Wiki.
- Wiki, I would cite the Wiki.
But like, I'm the kind of person
who like goes to the Wikipedia
and then ask the person to
confirm it if it's true.
'Cause you know, a lot of times
Wikipedia is full of shit.
They just write whatever
the hell they want.
- Actually, I don't think
I've ever even checked my own Wikipedia,
'cause I'm scared.
- There's a level of
restraint, I can expect.
- I am scared to see
what's written on there.
- I completely get that.
- I've checked.
We have, I don't have a Wikipedia,
I have like a YouTube Wiki
or something.
- That's like botchy,
I don't want that.
- The amount of misinformation on that
is just off the scale.
There's like a list of I think
like my best friends in
order on that Wiki page.
And it is like the most
botched list I've ever seen,
'cause-
- Best friends?
- Yeah, exactly.
- But like I was looking
at your Wikipedia and one part,
one aspect that I thought
was really interesting
was how you got started.
And it was like, you started
off by covering anime songs,
Vocaloid songs, and then
really specifically,
it said covering Avril Lavigne songs.
- Is this true?
- Is it true?
- Well, I've done a few of her songs,
but I wouldn't say I'm a
huge Avril Lavigne coverer.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I've done like two songs.
- Yeah, but it's weird,
because the Wikipedia
made it out to be like,
you are like the ultimate
cover artist for Avril Lavigne.
- Oh really?
- It specifically
named Avril Lavigne along
with anime and Vocaloid.
- Wow, I have an Avril
Lavigne genre in my Wikipedia,
that's-
- Yeah, for some reason, yeah.
I mean, but then again, when I saw that,
I was like, okay, that
kind of makes sense,
because you kind of do have a very,
like early 2000, Avril Lavigne-
- But I do love her.
I've grown up listening to her music,
but I wouldn't say I'm like-
- An Avril Lavigne genre?
- This is like turning
into an interrogation.
Are you really?
- That's really big for me, but yeah.
- So like, what made you
like upload your first songs?
Were you just like passing
time or did you just,
was this your outlet?
- Well, there was a time
in my, this is pretty deep.
This is pretty deep.
- Okay.
- We got time.
- There is a time
in my life where I was
completely like introverted.
I was a stay-at-home kind of person.
Even before all this Corona
happened, COVID-19 happened,
I was a stay-at-home person.
- Right there with you.
- Yeah, you're
preaching to the choir now.
- Yeah, so this is like
my generation right now.
So yeah, during that time though,
I still wanted to do music,
I still wanted to reach out to people.
So I thought, you know, oh yeah, internet,
great, that's really bendy.
Yeah, and so I started
uploading my own songs,
and lo and behold, I realized
that there was a huge
crowd out in the world
that I could reach out
to through the internet.
So that was my start.
- What was like your influences
for some of your early songs?
Was it mostly like anime and Vocaloid,
or was it just-
- Or was it Avril Lavigne?
- Well yeah, there you go.
Avril Lavigne, definitely,
can't live without her.
But yeah, definitely,
I listened to a lot of different
types of music growing up,
even from Disney to like British rock,
American rock, anime music, J-rock.
Like, I'm a huge widespread listener,
so I wouldn't just narrow it
down to one genre or artist.
- Right.
- Yeah, anime was a huge
start for me because anime music
was my introduction to
the Japanese culture,
just like you guys, and so, yeah.
- I mean, what confuses me almost is,
how do you go from doing covers to then
actually being the one
singing the anime opening?
What is that process like?
How do you go from-
- I'd like to ask
someone that myself.
To be honest-
- If you don't know,
who does?
- There's only
so many people out there on YouTube,
or on Niconico who are
like all these utaites
who are just like, if I just keep going,
I might end up being
the one singing, right?
- That's the thing.
Like, you have to just keep on doing it,
because that's what I did.
And, you know, whether you
end up where you end up,
it's, I don't know.
But if you don't continue
doing what you're doing,
then you're never gonna get there.
- So did someone scout you or did you go,
you know, sending in auditions or like,
what was the process like
to, I guess even get,
I guess, recognized by a company?
- Or just get signed, I guess?
- Yeah, before I started though,
I always thought that
you had to reach out,
you had to go there and get it yourself.
But if you keep doing the things you do
and you really enjoy what you're doing,
then you're gonna shine and
people are gonna listen to you
and people are gonna notice you.
So if what you're doing is right for you,
then I think that someone
out there is gonna find you.
And in my case, I was
lucky enough to be found
by my director who supported my debut.
So yeah.
- Okay, well, when was this?
Was this through YouTube
or through Niconico?
- It was through Niconico.
- Okay, so-
- Niconico is like-
- Japanese YouTube-
- Older version
of Japanese YouTube, right?
Was it focused on anime
or is it just everything-
- It was like Vocaloids at the time?
- Oh, wow.
- But I'm not a huge
Vocaloider, to be honest.
- Me neither.
- So I wasn't even like, you know,
I wasn't that knowledgeable
about Vocaloids,
but I was just covering
Vocaloid songs in English.
So that was my big start covering
- On Niconico?
- On Niconico.
- Oh, wow.
- So there weren't
a lot of people doing that-
- Yeah, I don't think
you have much competition on Niconico,
because they were like,
I think there's a small
dedicated community on YouTube
who translates and does
English song covers
of anime songs and Vocaloid songs.
But I've never heard
anyone posting on Niconico.
Mostly because nobody
can figure Niconico out.
- Well, the thing was,
there were like two people
covering Vocaloid songs in English,
but those people were not
native English speakers-
- Oh, God.
- So I was listening to that,
and I thought, hmm, there
could be something I could do.
Because I'm not that great at Japanese,
but I'm great at English,
so why don't I just do that in English?
And so I started doing that.
And then Japanese people
were like, oh, this is new.
- They're like, oh, eigo jouzu.
- Exactly, they're
like, why is this person
so good-
- What's her TOEIC score?
- So, you know, that kind of
sort of boosted up my views.
And then after that,
after the Japanese
people started watching,
then my songs started reaching out
to the overseas community globally.
So it was sort of like a, I don't know,
a ripple out into the world.
- Yeah, so would you, like,
would you say that you
were bigger on Niconico
than you were in YouTube back in the day,
or is that where you found your growth?
- Before I started Niconico, I was,
my listeners were more on a YouTube level.
But then from Niconico,
it went like, boom.
So I think my crowd
started bigger on Niconico.
- 'Cause what's always
fascinated me is the difference
between say like the YouTube anime culture
and just Niconico in general.
I feel like-
- Niconico's
like a different planet.
- Yeah, to me as like a Western anime fan,
I see some of the stuff
that's going on in Niconico
and it just, one, makes zero sense to me,
and two, seems to have
some of the most talented
creators I've like ever seen,
and nobody's heard about them
'cause they're on this
one Japanese website
that no foreigner can ever figure out.
- It's also insane with Niconico as well,
'cause like I used to go
on Niconico quite a bit,
like even before YouTube.
And it's just, yeah, as you said,
for some reason, creators on Niconico
are just on a different
level and none of them
like do it for like ad
revenue or anything.
They literally do it
out of passion and like,
so many utaites and Japanese singers
are all found on Niconico.
- What's an utaite?
- Utaite is basically,
do you wanna explain what an utaite is?
- Oh, you can do it.
- Oh, yeah.
Utaite is basically someone
who does like covers
of Vocaloid and anime and stuff like that.
Basically, it's like,
YouTube has its own version
of utaites called Youtaites.
- Oh, I think I have heard of it.
- Yeah, yeah.
So basically, it's just
like an amateur singer
who does covers of anime and Vocaloid
and stuff like that.
- Oh, that's cool.
- And then a lot of them
get major record label.
- So how long were you
uploading on Niconico
before you got like any kind of traction?
- I was completely newbie.
So there were so many bigger,
greater utaites before
me doing their thing.
And I just started and I uploaded,
I happened to upload my first videos,
I think it was like 2000,
really late 2010 into 2011.
And then 2011, early in 2011,
I got noticed by my director.
- Wow, that's fast.
- So it was like a few months.
And so I have no friends on Niconico.
Yeah, and my, probably
Niconico Wikipedia thingy,
my bumper is really like short and sweet.
- I mean, 'cause you were on
it for like, not even a year.
- I'll be honest.
If someone contact me like
four months into YouTube
and like, listen, I wanna
give you a record deal,
I'd be like, this sounds like a scam.
- Yeah, I thought so, I thought so.
But I got a direct sort of
contact through a creator.
- Oh, okay.
- So who is called
a Vocaliod-P, producer.
- So confusing.
- Yeah, I know.
The words on Niconico
are like really sort of,
lingo-
- Niconico's a different
planet.
- Niconico lingo.
- I'm trying to, I mean, it's
like when you go on TikTok,
you're like, what the
fuck is happening here?
Why is everyone singing can sea shanties?
What's going on?
- I haven't even got
that far, because to me,
I've always known about
the Vocaloid community,
but as someone who's quite
ingrained to the weeb culture,
I had, the Vocaloid fad
just kind of like went by
and I had no idea about anything
that was going on in that community.
- Legit, the only way I could understand
like half the memes that
were existing on Niconico
was to just like bite the
bullet and go on (indistinct).
I was like, 'cause it's all just there,
so I was like, oh fuck,
I guess I have to go
into this cesspool to understand it.
And even then, I can only
understand maybe like 30% of it
before I was like, I just don't get this.
I just don't get this at all.
- So like, what was the difference
between like say Niconico culture
and uploading to YouTube for yourself?
- Well, like you said, Niconico is very,
like a closed community.
Everyone is understanding.
They're like friends on there
and it's like a parallel universe.
- Are people nice on that platform?
- Very nice, very nice.
- Wow.
That is a parallel universe.
- Very nice, but I wouldn't
say that I'm too knowledgeable about it.
So yeah, but I just think that it's like
a universe in itself so they kind of move
along in the world at their own pace.
So that was kind of
different from YouTube.
YouTube is very open, it's worldwide,
and there's so many people on there.
- Yeah, 'cause I feel
like because Niconico
is so focused on the
kind of like the anime
and weeb side of the community,
that it feels much more closed off.
And especially with the
Japanese speaking as well.
But that just makes me
wanna get into it more,
because it seems like
an untapped goldmine.
- Are you sure about that?
- I mean, I don't know, I don't know.
'Cause I, from the outside looking in,
that seems to be like such
a goldmine of content there,
like especially people getting scouted
professionally on that platform just shows
that there is real
talent in that platform.
- Honestly, like, I'd say some of the best
anime-based memes have all
originated from Niconico.
- Is Niconico still a thing?
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Like, still popular?
- Yeah, Niconico is huge still.
- Really?
- Yeah, it's huge.
- Especially in Asia, it's big.
And I'd have to say, though,
the talent on Niconico
is amazing.
- Unmatched, unmatched.
- That's why I think
all these record labels-
- What?
- Who?
Kadokawa owns Nico, oh wow.
- Oh really?
I didn't know that.
- Wow, thank you.
Shadow-
- Such a great platform.
I don't know.
- I'm not endorsed to say that at all.
- I'm curious.
How do you then, okay,
so you get signed, right?
How long is it before you're
given this opportunity
to voice an anime opening and what,
are you allowed to tell
us about that process
and how it went?
- Yes, of course.
I would love it.
- I'm so-
- We have no idea.
We'd never heard of like
anyone's firsthand experiences
of going into that kind of stuff.
- Oh wow, yeah.
Actually, I've never actually
just really looked back
and thought deeply into this, but for me,
I wouldn't say that this
goes for every artist,
but for me, the first time
my director contacted me
wasn't to give me a
record deal or a label,
record deal to make a debut.
It was to do a collaboration on a song,
a cover song that was going
to be on a compilation album
that this record label
was going to release.
And so I sort of collaborated with them
to put one song on there.
And after that, the director said,
okay, so we've done one song together,
but what about we do a full
album, a debut album together?
So that was sort of my start.
And from there, it was
about a year, I think,
that we went into sort
of creation of this new,
my debut album.
And original songs had to be made.
And so it was about a year that it took
from me, from getting,
from meeting this director
until releasing my first album.
- Okay, so you, so this album was purely
just original songs that you
had to write within that year.
- Yeah, I did a few cover songs,
since my fan base was based on Niconico.
So I did a few Vocaloid
cover songs in English,
and I released a few original new songs.
And then after that, I released the album,
and then my first single
actually came after that.
So my first anime tie up was
later on, a few months later.
- Okay.
- So was that,
was recording an album
is like the first time
you were doing like studio work
or was it even in a studio?
- Oh my gosh, my first
time in an actual studio,
oh my gosh, that was crazy insane.
- How was that?
- Oh no, no, no, no, no, no.
That was like nerve-wracking
to the extreme.
Especially because it
was big, Victor Studio.
It wasn't like a small sort
of indie studio or anything.
It was like Victor Studio.
- It's a like a major
record label.
- Was it like
multiple people at the
other side of the glass,
like just watching?
- Exactly.
And oh my gosh, me alone in the booth.
And then all these like
official looking people, scary-
- Were you given like direction
and everything like that?
- Exactly, exactly.
- That's like
the first time I voice acted
in like a proper studio.
'Cause you always used to
just do it like in my house
in front of my family.
- Exactly.
I was a complete garage-bander.
- Yeah, and then all of a
sudden, you have headphones,
and being like, ah, can you
just do that again, please?
It's like, this is weird.
I hate the fact that people are watching
and I can't see them.
- Exactly.
And what I love about
doing DTM garage band
was that if you hated the take,
you could retake it like a hundred times,
and it was completely like your pace.
And if you wanted to perfect
it, you can perfect it.
But when you're in the studio
and there are people directing you
and doing your recording for you,
they kind of tell you what to do.
And even if you don't like
your take, you have to use it.
Or like-
- And there's like
a weird pressure where it's like,
I could do this a hundred times,
but I feel bad for making them wait.
- Exactly, exactly.
- Because that's paid
studio time, isn't it?
So you feel pressure to
have to kind of take them,
like optimize the time you have,
because you've only paid for a certain,
like a certain-
- You don't wanna do
like another take with
like the back of your head,
and you're like, ugh,
the director fuckin' hates me right now.
- When I was doing a lot
of voiceover in London,
I would like, I had this bad habit, right,
where I would flub a
line, instead of like,
just letting the line be bad
and just ask, can I redo it?
I would just say fuck at
the end of the sentence
so they couldn't use it.
'Cause it would be like, da-da-da-da fuck,
and then they couldn't use that.
But then they start getting angry at me,
like, "Don't do that, 'cause
we wanted to use that.
We could like splice it together."
So I had to stop doing that.
Even though I liked being
able to be like, nope,
I don't like that take, I'm gonna ruin it.
Let's do a new one.
- Yeah.
- So that was the huge
difference, I think,
from becoming amateur
to professional is that,
from that moment on, you
are doing your singing,
or your work for someone
or, you know, for work.
So it's an official thing
and it's not just for fun.
It's not a hobby anymore.
- Yeah.
I guess, how was the transition?
One of the biggest transition
is obviously getting paid for your work.
'Cause I feel like you started
off with this being a hobby.
How did it feel like
getting your first paycheck
doing what you love, or how did that feel?
- You know, like, but the
weird thing about music
is that it always continuously
feels like a sort of hobby.
And so it's probably
different from another
sort of type of work where
you go there every day
to do office work and it
just doesn't feel like work.
Like even when I'm
doing my singing career,
I'm always having fun.
I love doing what I love doing.
So it just never feels like work for me.
- That's the dream, isn't it?
- It is.
- Yeah, that is the dream-
- Doing what you love
and loving what you do, right?
- Yeah, I mean, 'cause for me,
like, I do my hobby for my job.
I'd talk about fuckin' anime.
- It's wonderful.
- But there are definitely,
there are definitely some days
where I wake up and it
does feel like work.
- Yeah.
- And it's usually
like mornings where I'm like, okay,
I have things to do, but I
really don't wanna do it,
'cause it's gonna feel like work.
Fuck it, I'm not gonna work today.
- The beauty of being self-employed, baby.
- Exactly.
- So when you made that album,
how was that kind of like distributed?
Was it aimed at like Japanese audience?
Was it aimed at like English audience?
Like what platforms?
I'm just, I'm curious
about the whole process
and how it was kind of
like aimed around, yeah.
- In the beginning, our
platform was based in Japan.
We were releasing stuff,
especially anime is based in Japan.
So our outlet was sort of
to the Japanese audience,
but somehow, little by
little, the global community-
- It's like they-
- Knew about me,
and I began doing sort of event lives
and things overseas as well like in Asia,
in America, in Germany, Australia,
I went to Australia as well, so yeah.
- Who-hoo!
Yeah! As the only Australian in this room,
I have to go, yay!
- Are there any Australians in the house?
- Me!
- Good day, mate.
- I don't wanna hear your British accent.
- Did you do the good day, mate on stage?
- I did.
- How did people take that?
- I had to do it.
- Who told you to do it?
- No, no one.
I just wanted to do it.
- No one?
- Is that like a thing that you do
for like different
countries that you go to?
Like, do you learn how to say like hello
or whatever in like different languages?
- I tried to, but at the same time,
I'm usually like restricted time-wise,
so I don't have time much to talk,
but if I had time to talk, I
would probably do a lot of-
- Hey guys, just gonna talk for
15 minutes before I perform.
I hope that's okay.
Like Kanye West.
- No time,
no time to sing, sorry.
- So how many places have you performed,
out of curiosity now?
- Mostly in Asia, but America, Australia,
Singapore, Malaysia, Indonesia, Germany.
- Okay.
- Whereabouts in America
did you go?
- San Jose, California,
Atlanta, Georgia-
- Is it like
anime conventions or just-
- Yeah, anime conventions.
And New York, which is my home city, so-
- How was it like performing
in your home city?
- Amazing, yeah, it was amazing.
Going, just going back there
felt like going home, so-
- Yeah, I felt that like two
years ago when I went back,
'cause I'm from Sydney in Australia.
So like we have a convention
in Australia called SMASH!.
- Oh.
- Yeah, like big,
big anime convention.
So like getting invited there as a guest
just felt so much better
than like any other
con experience I've ever been,
'cause it was like going
back home and being like,
look how much the city
has grown, so amazing.
Because I went to SMASH! in 2013
when there was like 2,000 people,
3,000 people, something like that.
And the year I went there was I think,
maybe 50, 60,000 people
that went to the con.
So just seeing how much it grew.
- That's insane.
- It was like, you know what?
I love my city.
This city's pretty freaking dope.
- The one time you feel patriotic?
- Yeah, yeah, one time where you look,
Ozzie, Ozzie, Ozzie!
- Meanwhile, I just see an
open field and I'm like, wow,
that's awesome.
- That's, that's,
that's a lot of sheep right there.
- You'd probably feel amazing though
if you were like invited to a
con in Wales, though, right?
- There's like non, there's like no con.
- I would like to get
invited to a con in Brighton,
but like the UK con scene
is just non-existent.
- Really?
- It's, yeah.
- As you would know.
- Because we have I
think, one big convention,
which is not even a convention.
It's like MCM and that's more like an expo
and that's like comic, gaming,
films, and also anime expo.
- Oh, right, right, right, like a-
- Were you a convention girl before
you started making music?
- Actually, I've never been to
a convention just by myself.
- Really?
- So that was a huge, big
culture, like experience for me.
- That's crazy, right?
- I feel like it's,
it would be scary to go to
a convention by yourself.
I don't know about you
guys's first convention, but-
- I mean, I didn't go until
I started YouTube, so-
- Really?
- Yeah, yeah.
Because I mean, well, I
mean, besides SMASH! in 2013,
but I was already doing YouTube back then,
like even then, I had to be like,
yo anybody in my area that
knows anything about anime,
I don't care if you've only watched
like one episode of "Dragon Ball Z,"
can you just come with me, please,
'cause I don't wanna
go by my, 'cause it's,
like even at a con with like
a couple thousand people,
it's just daunting going on your own,
because it's like, you get there,
and it's like, okay,
there's a bunch of people
who probably like the same stuff as I do.
But there's a part me
that feels really weird
just going up, being like,
"So you like anime, huh?"
Well, you can't really do that.
- I totally understand what you mean,
'cause I don't know how
to properly break the ice.
- Yeah, right.
- Also, it doesn't help
in the UK that no one talks to each other.
When someone talks to you,
you're like, whoa, what the fuck?
- I feel it'd be so
much easier in America,
because there's already
like this stranger
friendliness going on, right?
Like you can just talk
to someone on the street
and they probably will reply back to you.
- Probably, if you go to an
anime convention in America,
people would approach you sometimes
if you're just wearing a cool cosplay or-
- It won't work like that in Australia.
- No, not in England at all.
- I've never done cosplay before.
- Have you never?
- No, have you, have you?
- I haven't.
- Well, I've done quite a lot.
- Really?
- He kinda does that
for a living in a sense, yeah.
I've done it like once or twice.
- I'm not very good.
(all laugh)
When I say, when they
say I do it for a living,
that's very sarcastically.
- Wow.
- This episode is sponsored by ExpressVPN.
- So boys, I have a confession.
Yeah.
- I know we've been
living in Japan and all.
- Right.
- But I don't watch anime on TV here.
- What?
- Because I still need it subbed.
And that's why I use Crunchyroll
to watch my anime using ExpressVPN,
'cause Crunchyroll is
blocked here in Japan.
- I actually do that too.
- I sometimes do that too.
- I need the subs, man,
what am I supposed to do?
Learn Japanese?
No.
I'm wondering, Garnt, what
shows are you watching?
- Right now, I am
watching "Jujutsu Kaisen,"
"Slime" season two, and many more.
"EX-ARM" as well.
- But the good thing is
Express VPN lets you change
your online location
so that you can control
where you want sites
to think you're located
just by opening the app,
selecting a location,
tapping one button to connect,
and refreshing the page to access
thousands of new shows and
movies jJust like that.
- That's crazy, that's crazy.
Choose from almost 100
different countries.
Watch Studio Ghibli films on UK Netflix.
Watch anime on Japanese Netflix.
Watch "Doctor Who" on UK
Netflix and see many, many more.
- This also works on any streaming service
from Hulu, BBC iPlayer,
YouTube, and many more.
- You can stream in HD no
problem, no buffering or lag,
and it's compatible with all your devices,
phones, laptops, media, console,
smart TVs, and microwaves.
No, it doesn't work with your microwave.
- Not only does it let
you change your location,
it also encrypts your data and lets you
surf the web safely and anonymously.
That is why you should choose
ExpressVPN over other VPNs.
- So go to expressvpn.com/trashtaste
to get an extra three
free months for free.
That's expressvpn.com/trashtaste.
- That's crazy, you sure?
- I, that's what the script says.
- Wow, well back to the video.
- Right, so if you had
to start cosplaying,
who would be your first cosplay?
- Actually, like, I have no idea.
Any recommendations?
- You should do a cosplay of like,
either a "BTOOOM!" Character
or like an "Arpeggio" character.
Like, it would be cool if you did-
- "BTOOOM!", none of
the characters are cool.
There's (indistinct).
- Wasn't there one female
character in "BTOOOM!"?
- Yeah.
- That's all I remember.
- It was like blonde hair-
- It was the blonde-haired
girl, right?
- Yeah, in a school uniform.
- Well, that's what I'm saying.
I feel like "Arpeggio" would be
a lot more like cosplay-friendly,
'cause it's actually like
interestingly and it looks cool.
And like, it would be dope
if, say hypothetically,
you sang the "Arpeggio" opening-
- In a cosplay?
- In a cosplay
of "Arpeggio" character.
- Oh my gosh, that's really cheesy.
- That would be meta as fuck.
- That's very cheesy.
- It's cheesy, but you know,
you know con goers would
fuckin' fell over that.
- Well, outside of just like
anime that you've sung in,
what are some of your
favorite anime characters
that you would like to cosplay, I guess?
- I don't know, but-
- Like looks aside,
just anyone that you like.
- Ah, I don't know.
- I'm putting you on the spot
here, I just realized.
- Do you watch much anime
now still?
- Lately, I haven't
been able to watch much,
but I've always like in the past,
one of my favorite series have been like
"Full Metal Alchemist."
- My favorite, my favorite.
- Garnt is notorious for not-
- Really?
- He's notorious for
not having watched it.
As he should, 'cause
it's an amazing anime.
- It's all right.
- We're not gonna get into that.
- Yeah, we're not gonna get into that.
- But I usually get into
anime through the music.
I've always been a music lover.
So any anime with really
good music hooks me on,
and then I start watching it.
But I usually watch sort
of like adventure series
where the main character
is like a guy or a boy or,
not very like moe moe series-
- Right, right, right, right.
- I feel as well, like it made sense
with "Full Metal Alchemist,"
'cause the openings in that are bangin'
So many good openings-
- I haven't seen "Brotherhood" yet,
but like the first "Brotherhood" opening
is fuckin' legendary.
- Oh yeah, and also, you know,
the Asian Kung-fu
Generation opening as well.
Like yeah, it's so much
good music in that.
- When I listen to anime opening songs,
I can't figure out why I like
them, I just like the noise.
I'm curious if you have like a,
like, you must have an ear for it, right?
What makes like a good anime opening
in your opinion, I'm curious?
- If it's sung by me.
- Yours aside.
- You can say that as well.
- I'll keep that as a memo.
No, you know, I used to listen
to anime openings before I made a debut.
So what sort of hooked
me on was, you know,
number one, it's really catchy.
Number two, you know,
it captures the mood
of the anime very well.
And you know, I don't know, but number,
I don't, what makes an anime opening-
- I don't know, 'cause I have no clue.
I thought maybe you could answer that.
- I feel as though you
kind of answered that.
It is all about, like if
you just personally like it,
it sticks in your head, and
if it fits the theme, right?
- Usually though, you know,
if it's sort of, what do you call it?
Like kose deki, you know, individual then-
- Unique?
- Unique, yeah.
Then it sort of stands out.
And when something stands out,
then like it catches your attention.
- Yeah, because I remember
when I was in school,
I watched a load of anime
and people would ask me the question of,
what are some, what are
the music you listen to?
Who are your favorite artists?
- And I go through like
my iPod or something
and it's just all fuckin' anime openings.
- Pass me the (indistinct).
- And I'm just like,
oh, there's this really
like underground Japanese band
called like Asian Kung-Fu Generation.
You probably haven't heard of them.
- Look, that was the thing though, right?
It's like there was
some kind of like level
of like superiority in the
sense being like, yeah,
yes, I listen to
underground Japanese music
that you've probably never heard of.
- But now, I feel like everyone listens
to anime openings or anime music
'cause everyone figures
out that it slaps hard, so-
- Now, the superiority
is listening to a band
that's done an anime opening,
but listening to all the songs
that aren't in the anime.
- Exactly.
- That are like
every other song on the album.
It's like, you only know the opening,
I know the rest of the album.
- It's like, I've recently gotten into
like a lot of different artists
who are like in J-pop and J-rock
who have not been in anime openings
or have not done anime music,
but sound like they should
have done anime music.
And I feel like a lot of
those people and bands
really came up from
the Vocaloid community.
And I don't know, like that's why,
there's so much I don't know
about the Vocaloid community,
but everyone seems to have
come out of that community
and have this kind of genre of music
that just kind of appeals to weeb.
I can't like quantify in words,
but it's the kind of
music that I just love.
And I don't know what that
genre is, maybe utaites.
- Yeah, I guess it's like, yeah,
I know what you mean though.
It's like, even if the genre
is completely different,
there's just kind of like a stylistic
or like something about
it where it's like,
that sounds like it belongs in an anime.
Like you can very quickly
tell with with Japanese music,
if something is like made for anime
and something's not made for anime.
There's some quality about
it that I can't grasp
where it's like, that you can
tell the difference in that.
- But one thing I did
realize after making a debut
as a sort of anime singer
was that anime songs and,
well, I don't know how to say,
but regular J-pop or J-rock,
there is a distinct difference.
And you know, a lot of people
tend to like faster pace,
really like energetic songs in animes,
'cause you're limited
to one minute and 30
seconds of the opening
and it has to catch your attention.
So usually, the ballads
are saved for endings
and the really fast pace.
Which is why I started
seeing like BPM 200.
I'm just like dying in the studio.
'Cause I'd never sung BPM 200,
and after that, all my songs
became like really high pace sort of.
- I think I tried playing
some of your songs on osu!
and my mouse couldn't keep up.
I mean, what does that say?
- It's just like instant-
- I'm like, Jesus Christ,
this is going so fast.
- Yeah so, I really don't recommend,
like money-wise, yeah, please
do sing my songs at karaoke,
but I don't recommend like
singing my songs at karaoke
because of the sort of
level of difficulty.
- I mean, if you're having
a hard time singing them,
I don't know how some people,
how us peasant normies are
gonna be able to sing it.
- I personally would not
sing my songs at karaoke.
- It's like when you get like two drinks,
and you're like, yeah,
I think I can do Eminem.
And then you do it, and you're like,
I didn't remember this many lyrics.
Where were all these,
I thought it's just Slim Shady stand up.
What is this?
- It's not just Eminem.
It's like the really long,
like four verses Eminem.
- It's seven minutes long, what?
I thought it was three.
- Alternatively, where you
sing, you choose a song,
and you think you know the lyrics,
and then you realize you only know
about two sentences from the chorus.
And then there's just
this awkward one minute
where you're just kinda like
humming along to the verse,
even though you have-
(Joey stutters)
- Is it annoying being a singer
and then having to go to karaoke?
'Cause they expect you
to like kill everything
instead of just shouting.
- I have a secret, I sang
my own songs at karaoke,
and you know, they have
a really weird system
where they-
- Like the midi soundtracks?
- No, no, they have this weird system
where they like to give you
a score of how good you sing.
- I turn that off, I don't wanna know.
- I sang my own songs
and I got like a 60%.
So I was like (laughs)-
- Someone out there is
higher on the leaderboard.
- Exactly, I'm like, wow.
- It's like, when Charlie Chaplin entered
like a Charlie Chaplin lookalike
contest and came in third.
That's like the equivalent.
- The points where they
score you are really,
are very distinct.
And I tend to do arrangements
and do stuff with my songs.
I don't sing it exactly
like I did at the studio.
So that automatically
like score things lower-
- Those games do like the pitch,
it's truly off pitch, right?
So it's just like, you can just go, oh,
and it'll like, it'll
give you like perfect-
- It's just like very basic sing stock.
I don't how how they're scored.
I'm a bad singer, so I
I've never scored well
on any of those kinds of karaoke games.
- Well, I turn it off, I don't wanna know.
I don't wanna know how
bad I am at singing.
It's very bad.
- Have you ever been in the group
who hasn't known that you are a singer,
and then you just start
singing your own song,
and they're like, wait a minute.
You sound just like that
person singing the song.
- Nah, can't be, it's like 60%.
- Actually, ever since I made a debut,
I haven't been to karaoke
because it became,
singing became my career.
Like, it's difficult to do it for fun now.
- I mean, it's just work for you and it's-
- And when I start singing,
I automatically feel like I'm on stage.
So I think that's a little bit
heavy for the karaoke goers.
- So I thought we're having fun, what?
- Having a private concert right here.
That's a little bit of a flex, right?
Going to a karaoke and
singing your own songs.
That's a bit of a flex.
- So if I do happen to go,
then I usually am the one
like just putting everyone's
songs into the machine.
- Tambourine.
- Yeah, I love doing the tambourine.
- I guess though it would
be such a weird pressure
to go to karaoke with you.
You absolutely kill
your songs and be like,
oh, fuck, now I got to do "Sexy Back."
It's just the difference.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I wanna know,
when you started doing the anime openings,
how did that affect the album
that was already out and how like your,
I guess your like level
of fame, if you will,
and how it all kind of,
did you see any like results
from doing anime opening?
- Definitely, I think my
fan base sort of changed.
Of course, my original
fans stuck with me loyally,
very loyally.
- As they normally do
in Japan.
- Yes, exactly.
Which is really an amazing thing.
But at the same time, like,
I started out with my fan
base being mostly girls,
because on Niconico,
I think a lot of the fan base
was very like female-based.
My fan base was female-based.
But after I made an anime debut,
so "BTOOOM!," "Arpeggio,"
that made my sort of male fan base grow.
And that was huge.
When I went overseas and did concerts,
I was really happy to
see that my fan base,
my audience was kind of like a hybrid.
Everyone was there, not just like females-
- Like anyone can enjoy it.
- Yeah, exactly.
And so, you know, and I always
have loved rock and roll.
So I think it's not necessarily
a gender-based music genre.
So I was really happy
to see that my fan base
was growing globally in
diversity, and so that was-
- You kind of went through
a similar thing, right?
Like you went from like a
primarily female fan base
to a more of a hybrid now, right?
- Yeah.
- Was it,
was it like similar to
you where it's like,
you kind of saw that like it diverse-
- Well, he didn't have an
anime to jumpstart his-
- Well, I mean, yes.
- He just went from-
- He mostly jumped off one.
- Yeah, exactly.
- So to sort of give you a rough example,
I basically used to pretend
to be a British butler.
Isn't that fun?
- Oh, that's,
how do you pretend to be a British butler?
- Well, you just turn up the
British accent more than usual.
So you'd go like, oh,
I suppose I could talk
like this, you know.
- He was an actual living
anime avatar for a while.
- Yes, I didn't use to
like show my face much,
just do stuff like that.
But anyway, that, as you can imagine,
that kind of thing would attract
more of a female audience than-
- Exactly, which is
why fan base is female,
because I didn't show my
face in the beginning.
And my voice is pretty
low for a female singer.
So a lot of people didn't know my gender.
And so they assumed,
there was a huge fan base
that assumed that I was a young boy.
- Right, right, right.
- So you can imagine
the shock.
- A shota boy.
- You can imagine the shock
when I did my first concert,
probably.
- Like, what the fuck?
I wanted a young boy.
- I'm sure there were
audience people like that.
But you know, after I started
showing my face, though,
my fan base started to
become more diverse,
and not just to one genre.
- How did, I mean, did you
ever use to have fan interactions?
And if so, how did that change
when you went from that audience?
'Cause I noticed a very distinct change
in how my audience, I suppose,
behaves and talks to me
when I went to more male.
- Yeah, but personally, I didn't have
much interaction with my fans until my-
- Conventions.
- Yeah, my conventions
and my lives.
And so I don't really have like comparison
between my Niconico
days and my debut days.
But definitely, I love
being able to interact
with like my listeners right now.
This is amazing.
I love being able to hear them,
hear their voices directly.
And so like, I have no regrets
about like going open with
my identity and stuff.
- 'Cause do you feel
like it really hits you
when you go to a convention
and you physically
see the people that are in front of you
that you're performing in front of?
Because for us, YouTubers,
we see a number,
and the number kind of just-
- Doesn't mean anything.
- Means nothing.
- You don't see a face.
- Yeah, we don't see a face.
And then we try to like,
even trying to quantify it
in our heads, it's just,
it doesn't mean anything
until we go to a convention
and we actually see the amount
of people in front of us
and we're like, oh,
these people all know me?
Jesus Christ, that's a lot of people.
- It's kind of insane how
it's like a million views
on a YouTube video seems so much smaller
than physically seeing a hundred people
in front of you.
- I know.
- And it's such a weird
dichotomy how that works.
And it's like, yeah, and it's like,
we could be happy with all the views
we get on all the videos,
but at the end of the day,
it doesn't really, you
can't see anything, right?
That doesn't mean, it
doesn't really mean anything.
I mean, it means something,
but it doesn't mean as much as it should.
- It's not as weighty-
- Yeah, exactly, exactly.
- Before you debuted,
had you ever performed
on a big stage before
or anything like that?
- No, my first ever
concert in my entire life
was in front of 2,000 people.
- Wow.
Oh my God.
- A solo concert.
So when the curtain
went up, I almost like-
- Hi, guys.
- You know, I was like,
my voice is gone.
- Just went up two octaves.
- So like I almost died on stage.
- What's the biggest crowd
you've ever performed in front of?
- It was at an event, Anisama.
So that was probably like ichiman,
so 10,000-somewhat number of people.
But when it becomes that sort of number,
you can't see the faces, so
it's like a sea of lights,
of like penlights and people,
so you don't become nervous anymore.
It's just like, it's more nerve-wracking
when you're in a small venue
and you see every single face
and they're all looking at you.
- It's the eye contact that
really gets you, I find.
- Because we don't have that experience.
I mean, like, what's the
biggest amount of people
you've done a panel-
- I'd say AX, right?
- AX, I think.
- 3,000.
- Garnt and I hosted in front
of like 3, 2, 3000 people.
And that, I was shitting my pants.
- Yeah, I hate it when
you just make eye contact
with someone for like two seconds,
and you're like, do you
reckon they noticed?
They 100% noticed.
That was that weird,
that was weird, right?
- Can you imagine doing a panel
in front of 10,000 people?
- I would like to not.
- Yeah,
I would like to not either.
- I got to ask, do you
ever get, is it like,
do you ever get nervous
before going on stage?
Do you ever get used to that?
- I'm not a huge, like a nervous person.
So I'm usually pretty like
excited to go on stage,
and I'm like, I'm gonna have fun,
woo-hoo, this is my home, you know?
So I really don't get nervous.
But when I do get nervous
though, it doesn't,
it's every time, I do
get a little bit nervous,
but I love being on stage.
- Because I feel for me, it's,
I don't know if it's nerves,
but I just, it's the
waiting that kills me.
I just wanna get on stage,
whenever I have like a
panel scheduled or whatever
and there's a lot of people,
I just feel like once I get
on stage, I'm gonna be fine,
but before that, I'm just restless.
- It's like you're backstage,
and you just hear the murmur of the crowd.
That's when it's the most nervous.
But the moment I start
like going up the stairs,
it's just gone.
- That's exactly true.
Like, I hate the waiting of it.
The waiting is the most
nerve-wracking point.
Once you're on stage,
then you just gotta do what you gotta do.
- Did you discover like the
first time you're on stage,
was it like an aha moment?
This is, I love this.
- Oh, I thought, yeah, this is
definitely where I wanna be.
I'm so grateful to have this chance
to actually do what I love doing.
And I don't know, it's just,
this is perfect for me.
- Yeah, 'cause I assume it's
kind of like a trial by fire,
'cause you said you had no
stage experience before.
'Cause I can only imagine
some other artists
who just kind of didn't
take the stage as well
would have fallen flat.
- I went on stage in
Japan for a video recently
where I did like a visual kei video.
And it was awful, I hated it.
Because it was like 30 people,
so it was very intimate.
And because, also COVID, no
one was allowed to like move.
Everyone just had to stand,
which makes it even worse,
'cause I wasn't doing anything.
I was headbanging, but
anytime I stopped and made
even like a millisecond of
eye contact with someone,
and they were just like, I was like,
oh my God, I'm awful, I'm terrible.
I'm ruining the whole thing.
Yeah, needless to say, I
was not happy about it.
- It's like doing a performance
in front of your family.
And they're just like being like-
- But at least your family,
you know your family's
gonna have your back
no matter what.
- Right, right, right.
- I figured out, when I have
to go on stage and do something
to actually be good at it,
that's when I get nervous.
'Cause I'm like, people have expectations.
When you know that it's
okay to be bad at it,
and like, that's the whole
joke, yeah, I like that,
because it's like, all right,
I'm just gonna be a clown.
That's what they came here for,
so that's what I'm gonna do.
- And I guess that's like the benefit
of like doing a panel for Australia
is that like most if not all the people
who are attending it know us enough
that even if we fuck up
slightly, they'll be like,
ahaha, that's just
him being him.
- Yeah, because
I have no talent,
so what am I gonna do on stage?
- But I find, I've only really,
my career took off in Japan,
so I'm not an American-based singer,
but at the same time,
I grew up in America,
and I've been going to
concerts in America.
And I did realize after my debut
that the Japanese sort
of entertainment industry
is completely different from the American-
- 100%.
- 100% different,
and the sort of expectations
in Japan are very high.
You have to be perfect.
A lot of people require
perfection as part of the job.
So that is always very nerve-wracking
to be able to have to sort of think,
oh, I have to perform perfectly on stage,
but that's impossible.
- I feel like it's even
like when you're ordering
a drink at Starbucks
here, they think like,
oh my God, they're gonna hate me,
I didn't put the little straw in.
And it's like, no, no, no, it's okay.
I feel so bad they're freaking out.
But I mean, how is the difference
between performing in
Japan and say, America?
- You know, like in America, I
feel that when I go on stage,
it's like a live, it's
really like a live thing.
It's a live experience,
you're with your fans,
you don't, nothing is planned.
Your set list is planned,
but everything else is like-
- Got a lot more freedom.
- Yeah, it's freedom.
It's up to luck.
But in Japan, I think even
the fans are very loyal
in the sense that they really
want you to do your best.
And they're always like
hoping you do your best.
But the expectations are
completely different.
I do love performing in Japan
as much as I do love
performing overseas as well.
But at the same time-
- it's just a different experience, right?
- Yeah, I feel that Japan
is more based on like,
just doing things excellently
to the best as you can,
always being, you know, just perfect.
- Has anything bad ever happened on stage
or something that you didn't predict,
that you'd kind of just had
to deal with on the spot?
- Luckily, I haven't had huge misses,
but I'm always, the fear of
miss messing up is like here.
- It's healthy, though, I think.
You got to have that, right?
If you're too complacent-
- That's very true.
- I feel like you won't do
your best.
- But it does appear
as nightmares in my dreams often.
Like I don't know how many-
- You wake up in a cold sweat
and you're like, oh, what
if I fuck up on stage?
- I don't know how many
times I've had nightmares
where I completely messed up my lyrics,
or like I don't even know
my own songs on stage,
or like, I'm like what
am I doing on stage?
I don't even know what to sing.
I don't know, my lyrics
are completely washed out.
So I think like somewhere in my head,
I'm always like, that's a fear
of mine messing up on stage.
- So like, how has, I suppose,
how has COVID kind of
affected your schedule?
What'd you like, what's a
day in the life of nano?
What'd you do now that
you can't go on stage?
- What are you up to, huh?
- What am I up to?
But like I said, though,
as like a regular nano,
not like a musician nano, I'm
a very stay-at-home person,
so this is very, like,
not too different from my-
- Comfortable, comfortable.
- Yeah, it's not too different
from my-
- You're in your comfort zone.
- But last year, in 2020,
I had a lot of overseas
events planned, a lot of,
my own tour was actually
canceled last year due to COVID.
So in the music industry though,
COVID has really taken its toll.
And that's not just me,
for all the musicians and
entertainers out there.
So we're really struggling in that sense
to be able to find new ways
to reach out to the audience
and to give back to the audience
even without being able to
directly interact with them.
But that's, I think a
good sort of start for us.
- Yeah, 'cause I assume
that being at home,
have you had more time
to work on new music or-
- Yeah, we've been doing
a lot of creating at home,
so we're using, we're trying
to use our at-home time wisely.
We've been creating
music and getting ready
for when the time comes when
we're able to do lives again.
- Gonna be a hell of a comeback.
- Yeah, hopefully.
- Honestly,
once COVID is gone, the amount of concerts
that are just gonna pop up out of nowhere.
I don't know the time to
go to all these concerts.
- I'm just wondering, there's
gonna be so many events
that I want to go to when
things start opening up again.
My schedule is gonna be so packed.
- But with non-work.
- I just wanna go to the cinema.
I miss, you can't even get popcorn.
It's so sad.
- I know.
- They're like, you can go to the cinema,
and you can sit next to other people now,
but the reason, it used to be
to socially distance with one seat,
now you can sit next to each other.
But the drawback is you're
not allowed to have popcorn.
- Oh no, then I'm not going.
- I never buy popcorn.
- It's the best
part of the theater.
- I hate it because it's,
'cause as you saw earlier,
I go to the toilet all the freaking time-
- Yeah, me too.
- So when I eat popcorn, I get thirsty,
so I have to drink, but then
I have to go to the toilet,
and I'm gonna miss some of the film.
So I almost, I've learned my lesson now.
I have the bladder of a five-year-old boy,
so I'm just gonna not order popcorn.
- A little trade secret.
So when we record Trash Taste,
we have to take a break every 30 minutes
to reset the cameras,
and me and Joey go to the toilet
basically every time-
- Almost every time.
- During the breaks,
because we have a very small bladder.
- Embarrassing, embarrassing.
- That's why I know now, it's just like,
I'm just not gonna get popcorn anymore.
I love it.
Like if I'm with someone
and they have a bucket of popcorn,
yeah, I'm taking that shit.
- Popcorn's the one food
that I don't buy for myself.
But when someone offers me it,
I never say no.
- I always take it.
- I'll say no for you, my popcorn.
I wanted that, I'm eating all of that.
- Wow, rude.
- Should take a break?
I do actually need the toilet.
- [Connor] This episode is
sponsored by Custom Cast,
an app available on
iOS and Android devices
that let you achieve your dreams
of becoming a virtual, ah-
- [Joey] Cute anime girls.
- [Connor] Not what I was
about to say, but yes,
the Custom Cast app
lets you create your own
customizable virtual avatar.
- [Joey] In the free basic version,
you can create your own
high quality 3D avatar
in just a few minutes.
You don't even need a phone number
or a social media account to register.
- [Garnt] Hello, gentlemen, ara, ara.
You can customize your avatar
with many different hairstyles, clothes,
backgrounds, body sizes, et cetera.
- [Joey] You can always choose to be
a kawaii anime girl like me and Garnt.
- [Connor] Or you can try and make
your character look like
you, but cooler, like me.
- [Garnt] I can't get over
how cute you look, Joey.
- [Joey] I know, right?
You kind of look like
an older sister, Garnt.
- [Garnt] And we're not related by blood.
- [Connor] What the, get out of here.
Anyways, if you feel like going all out,
you can also make in-app purchases
to unlock tons of unique features.
- [Garnt] And if you want to
use your avatar to stream,
all you have to do is select
the stream button on home
and you're all set to
make your VTuber debut.
- [Connor] Your face will be detected
by the virtual camera on your device
and your virtual character will move
based on your facial
expressions and movements
such as tilting or turning your head.
- [Joey] You, too, can become the waifu
or hasbando of your dreams,
since both girl and boy
avatars can be created.
- [Garnt] So check the links
in the description below
to give it a download.
And now I'm sad, I'm gonna have to go back
to my real persona for
the rest of the show.
- [Connor] Thank you for sponsoring
this episode, Custom Cast.
Now, back to the episode.
- So like you talked
before about the pressure
of performing in Japan because
they expect perfection.
And we've talked before on this podcast
about like idol culture in Japan
and how they kind of expect perfection
not only like on the stage,
but off the stage as well.
- Like as a person.
- You really get put on a
pedestal here, it seems like.
What's it like in your position?
Do you feel like you have the pressure
to be like perfect in
every aspect of your life?
Or do you just not give a shit?
- Well, during, for example,
like the concerts themselves
are completely different, like I said.
Japanese audiences tend to sort of enjoy
the MC talking sections a lot.
And so they like to hear
about like your private life,
and what you're doing and
they like to hear your talk.
But then the, for example,
the overseas audience,
they just wanna like have fun.
- Where's the music?
- Sing!
- Play the anime opening!
- Exactly, so, you know,
I ended up not talking much
on stage when I go overseas.
But yeah, I think in the
Japanese industry though,
they have like, they have exactly image
of what kind of concert they wanna do.
And then you do that
exact kind of concert.
And then also the fans have like a very,
they like to like make you a character.
You became a character sort of thing,
so it was kind of interesting though.
Like I became a nano
character in the beginning.
I tried to sort of live
up to that expectation,
but then I realized that, you
know, it's kind of impossible.
So little by little, like I'm
becoming a lot more freedom,
and right now I'm just, you know me, but-
- Have you ever had any
uncomfortable situations
arise from trying to be more yourself
and the fans wanting this
perfect image of you?
- Well, I did sort of think about like,
oh, is this what sort of character
nano would do or say or not?
You know, that kind of things?
- That's weird,
'cause you are nano.
- Yeah, exactly.
- What would the fans
think that I would do,
I should do that.
- What is like the main difference
between the character nano
and like you as just nano?
- It was really sort of distinct,
because I didn't show my
face in the beginning.
So anything that sort of showed
like a personality-
- On stage as well?
- No, on stage, I did, but I mean photos,
since I'd never showed my
face in photos and stuff.
And so anything that sort of showed
a characteristic of myself,
the human side of nano.
- So if I'm understanding this correctly,
they created a character not like,
did they make a lore
around it or was it just
how they perceived the way
you would act off-camera?
- Well, it was kind of like
my artist's image as well.
So my director also wanted
to go in a direction
where I was not too open,
I was more mysterious,
and who's nano?
Are they a boy or a girl, I don't know.
- Japanese audiences love that shit.
They love the mysterious character-
- Because you can then apply
based off the music and
performance, is you can think like,
oh, I think they're like this
and they must be like this.
- But actually, it did help
me focus on my music more,
because I didn't have to think
about what I looked like,
what my image was like, I
could just focus on my music
and not focus on the other
aspects of, the visual aspects.
- Yeah, because I feel
like a lot of people
forget that in the music industry,
sometimes a lot of like image
is just as important as the music as well.
So being able to focus on the music
I feel is a big advantage, 'cause you can,
that just means you can just focus
on what you're really passionate about.
- Yeah.
- Well, it's always like,
they always think that people
on like X Factor and American Idol.
- American idol.
- Because they're
too humanized to us and that we see them
way too similar to ourselves,
they don't really work
very well as pop stars,
'cause they're not
larger-than-life characters.
So I feel like in almost some aspects,
you kind of have to not tell everyone
about everything about yourself.
'Cause they're gonna think like,
oh, well I know everything about her now,
she's like a normal everyday person.
But if it's like, oh my God,
mysterious person who is amazing at music.
- Perhaps, now that I'm completely myself-
- My fantasy is ruined.
- The facade is gone.
We are breaking the fourth wall now.
- Yeah, I saw like, it's
very similar to like,
I read this article on the reason
why Daft Punk hides their faces now.
It's because like, yeah,
it's exactly the same thing.
It's like, they just wanna like
completely focus on the music,
they wanna basically
cut off the connection
between the person making the
music and the actual music.
So now, the two members of Daft Punk,
they can do whatever the fuck
they want in their personal life
and no one can say anything otherwise.
- They could be at their own concert
in the crowd and no one
would actually know.
- But that was so convenient
because I could go anywhere
and do anything without
people realizing who I was.
So I could go to the convenience store
in my pajamas and be like, woo-hoo!
- Would you do that when
you had your face hidden?
- Oh, definitely, I still do.
- Have you ever been noticed
or recognized in Japan?
- Actually, no, I haven't.
- Really?
- What if you have, but they
just didn't come to you?
What if they're like totally Japanese?
- From a distance.
- Wait, on my Wikipedia,
does it say that I go to
convenience stores in my pajamas?
- It does now.
- nano was spotted on
so and so and so day in her
pajamas at a FamilyMart.
- Was it TMZ that does that now?
Is there like a Japanese TMZ?
Or-
- I don't know.
- Just seem like the YouTuber TMZ.
- What's the YouTuber TMZ?
- It's like YouTuber TMZ.
- Oh no, I have seen that.
- It's really creepy.
They like follow, like the 13-year-olds-
- Tubefilter, right?
- Something like that.
- They like stalk
13, 14-year-old TikTok stars
and just ask them questions.
And it's like, what do you-
- It's mostly-
- It's mostly in LA, right?
- Yeah, of course it's LA.
- 'Cause I see some of
those TMZ YouTubers now,
and I get this image
that just LA YouTubers
live on different planets.
- LA's on a different planet.
LA just works differently
from the rest of the
world, I'm pretty sure.
- But I've spent so much
time not having an identity.
So for like years and years,
I spend doing music just
without an identity.
So now that I do have an
identity and I'm more free now,
sometimes I don't know who I am.
Sometimes I'm like lost
at that point, but-
- Yo, this is getting pretty deep.
But no, I totally get it though.
- It's like, it is a
very uncomfortable thing
where you're like, hm, am I the character
that people think I am, or am I-
- What is nano?
- This is stressful.
- Because I've experienced
like something similar
doing YouTube where I don't
know if my personality,
because my personality has shifted
in like the 10 years I've done YouTube.
But have I shifted
because I've done YouTube
or have I shifted because
of my own personal reasons?
I don't know.
- The way I try
and like tell people, at least
I think I tell myself this,
to, like, this is right, right?
Like, I think I present
like an image of myself
that is like me on my best days.
'Cause obviously, you get sad,
you get those days where
you don't wanna do anything
and you're a little not fun-
- You sure you're here?
- Kinda not fun to be around,
obviously, I'm not going to show that.
But then it's like, am I
lying by not showing that?
Like, I don't know, I hate this.
- Exactly.
- So uncomfortable.
- 'Cause I feel like that
when there's a camera,
I feel like I have to be
in like the good mode,
the entertaining mode where sometimes,
you just don't feel like
being entertaining or talking.
- I just got to like take
the smile pill, right?
And like, I'm on camera now, hey!
Yeah, it's tough.
And I feel like I can completely see why,
especially on the YouTubers, right?
Why there is kind of
been this like kind of,
I've almost seen as like a growing thing
of faceless YouTubers,
just because I think
people are starting to realize
the kind of, not risk per se,
but the demerits to like showing your face
and showing your self on camera.
- It's way more pressure.
And I've noticed that since,
because I started off with most people
not knowing much about me,
and then Trash Taste started,
and now I'm on camera every week.
And it's something that I
just haven't been used to.
- I'm so lazy.
I just can't be bothered
going through all the effort
of like hiding my identity.
- But yeah, like I said earlier, though,
I think the Japanese industry-
- They like that?
- The entertainment industry
used to be very sort of strict,
and they expected you to sort
of portray an artist's image,
like idols and-
_ Like it was a,
it would be a bit huge scandal, right,
if they were dating someone.
- Exactly.
But thanks to YouTube and like,
this recent sort of generation,
a lot of musicians and entertainers
are starting to become YouTubers.
And I think that's a huge
plus because they're realizing
that they can be themselves
more and still work.
- And be human, right?
- Yeah, and be human.
And people are actually
looking for that now.
And so this is a huge, a big sort of plus
for the entertainment industry,
and I think it's a good change for us.
And I feel it's a chance for
us to be more of ourselves
and to really put out our
own messages into our work.
- Did you have any control
over your own like artist's image,
or was that all-
- Not at the beginning.
This is my first time
actually talking about this,
and I would love to talk about it.
- A Trash Taste exclusive!
- Let's go,
let's go.
- Exclusive.
No, but everything in the
beginning of my career,
because I was completely an amateur.
I wasn't, like usually rock artists
start doing their stuff
before their debut.
Like they do small lives venues,
they do tours, they have a fan base.
But for me, like day one that my fans
made a debut with me
was my day one as well.
And I didn't do lives before that.
I didn't have media coverage
or anything out there.
So it was just Niconico.
And so I needed aid, I needed direction.
And so my director made
sort of this image of who,
what kind of artist I should be.
And I tried to sort of be
that, I said that I could.
So in the beginning though,
everything was completely like, you know-
- Decided for you?
- Yes, decided for me.
And I didn't even know what
I wanted yet as a musician.
So I couldn't say, hey,
I wanna do this, I wanna,
I just wanted to sing, that's
all that I wanted to do.
- And that's how it normally
is. Artists just kind of,
a lot of thing I noticed about artists
is that they just wanna focus on the art,
and they have no idea about
how to market themselves
or branding.
- So it really helped me
to have the direction and
to be told, like, you know,
everything other than
the singing part to do,
how to do this, how to do that.
They taught me about the
entertainment industry,
they taught me how to do lives,
they taught me how to
take artist's photographs.
They taught me everything.
- God, I wish I knew that.
- Yeah, we just kind of
had to learn on the job
and take an array of
the most awkward photos
that have ever been taken.
- But in the beginning,
it was so sad because
I didn't show my face,
but I had to take artist's photographs.
So I was always wearing a hood.
And so I was like standing
in front of the camera
wearing a hood and not showing my face.
And I was like, you know, this could be-
- Anyone else could do it.
- Anyone else.
It could be a mannequin
and no one would notice.
Does it have to be me?
That kind of thing.
Even in my promotion videos,
I didn't show my face,
and so my neck was always like this,
and by the end of the video,
I'd be like, oh my neck, my neck.
So that happened behind the cameras.
And there were a lot of things
that were difficult in the beginning.
But now that I think about
it, it was really funny.
It was really funny and fun.
And it helped me learn
about a lot of things.
- Did you have, did you
ever have that point
where you had to like
work on your signature,
or did you have a good looking signature
to begin with when you sign things?
- I just use, I still use to this day,
just a regular, like cursive signature.
- I'm so jealous.
- I literally just do like four circles,
and I'm like, bam, bon appetit.
- I would love to have a
cool looking signature,
but I don't know how to
do it because I never-
- I think Joey out of all of us
has the coolest looking signature.
- Which is hilarious, because I came off,
that signature-
- Really, show me
your signature.
- My signature?
Do we have like a thing?
'Cause like I came up with my signature,
I think, in like, it was the
first con I ever went to.
It was basically the first time
I ever had to sign something.
Like someone came up to me and was like-
- And you made up-
- Hey, man, I love your work.
Can you sign something?
And I'm like, who the fuck
wants a signature from me?
- You made that up on the spot?
- I made that up on the
spot and I was like,
you know what, good enough.
This is just gonna be my
signature for the rest of my life.
- 'Cause while Joey is
doing his signature,
because I remember the first time
I got asked to do my signature,
I looked like a lost deer in headlights.
Look at that, that's-
- That's my signature.
- That looks cool.
That looks like a proper
artist's signature.
- I could sell that on Yahoo.
- Yeah, I literally always like, okay,
what is like a distinct
thing about a signature?
Lots of like unnecessarily long lines.
Lots of like overlap,
to the point where it needs
to be illegible, basically.
- Let me show you how it's done, Joey.
- So show me your signature-
- Mine I think is in between
a little of both.
- And I was like, okay,
I can't just like write The Anime Man.
(all laugh)
- I can see that you probably
came up with that in-
- That seems like-
- That looks like Cdan.
- Am I looking at Rorschach image here?
- Listen, you think when
Picasso was in the museum,
he had to put up with this shit?
Listen, let me explain, all right?
You have the C, the D, and
then I just do whatever.
It's always like I do the
C and D and I give up.
- This is like, you know-
- And Garnt's signature?
- Okay, I'll do it.
This is like when the kid
brings back a drawing.
- We have to see yours
as well.
- Yeah,
this is like when the kid brings
like a drawing to their parents
when they're like three or something
and the parents have to act impressed.
Like, oh, you did this?
Oh, it looks so good.
- It's not even that.
It's just like, put it on the phone.
- When I'm signing the packages in Japan,
they'll be like, oh,
full signature please.
And I'm like, oh, of course, of course.
Then I just do that, and they're like,
they look at me like, what was that?
That wasn't full signature.
- That's mine.
It's not as good as Joey's, but-
- That's pretty clean.
- It's okay.
- Hold it up to the camera.
- Show that on camera.
- It's okay, it's okay.
It's not bad.
- Yeah, see, I can read that
and be like, yeah, that
clearly says Gigguk.
I look at this and I'm like, who's Dan?
- Honestly, this is
cleaned up a lot, because-
- I have a unique one every time.
This is bullshit.
Why would I want this?
- I thought-
- You wanna do yours
while we're waiting?
- Okay.
- I thought one thing that differentiates
between like a regular signature
and an artist's signature
is like they have some
kind of like thing in it.
Yeah, see, that's clean.
- That looks good.
That looks good.
- But you know,
I'm actually looking.
- Wait, wait.
Put it up to the camera.
- Put it up to the camera.
- See that's clean.
- No, I'm actually
looking for a new signature.
So you guys can think of one for me.
- I got you, say no more,
I'll make one for you.
- So like wait, so-
- Which kind of style
do you like the most?
- One hint I need is a lot of like-
- A lot of squiggles,
I like the squiggles.
- A lot of pointless lines, right?
- Monocles, higher IQ.
- But my name is pretty
difficult to do that with.
- I mean, just go as cursive as you can.
You're like, this is, put on
the top hat and the monocle.
- I go for the doctor note-
- I kinda like this.
- Yeah, right, see?
See?
- Yeah, I kind of like,
Cdan-
- It's my Cdan.
- Pointing at my signature, by the way,
you can get that on the record.
- Yeah, I kind of like this one.
So maybe I'll just like get rid of the O
and just go Cnan.
- Yes.
- It's more C, I think.
- I like that.
- That's good.
- That looks like,
that looks like it says Chon.
- Chen, Chen.
- Chen.
Oh yes, my favorite artist, Chen.
- I'll have to ask my staff, though,
if this passes for the-
- Do you have to get your
signature approved by your staff?
- Not usually, but in this case, probably.
- When it's this bad, it's like, oh God.
- I got to ask,
have you guys ever had a fan
ask you to redo a signature?
- Oh yeah, I have.
- 'Cause I've had that before.
That's why, because my signature
looks a lot better than it used to,
because before, it used to
look something like this.
And I remember, I put this
on like a guy's shirt,
'cause he wanted me to sign a shirt,
and he deadass looks at that,
and he was like, "Can you
do that again, please?
I can't read that."
- I got a good one for
you, can I have the pen?
- All right.
- So I was at a bar
with a friend in the
middle of nowhere in Japan.
And for some reason, he
thought it'd be entertaining
to tell the person at the
bar that I was a YouTuber.
I really don't wanna do that.
- I hate it when they do.
- It's just like, you're not
gonna get it if I show you,
and you're not, you're
only gonna be impressed
by the numbers and not
wanting to (indistinct).
So it's like, don't do it.
So he does it, anyway,
so I'm like quite drunk,
and they're like, can you please,
for some reason they brought
out a shikishi, like 2:00 a.m.,
and I'm already pretty, I'm pretty drunk.
So they hand it to me and I'm
trying my best to do this.
So all I do in the end is just this.
I do this.
And they were like, "Whoa!"
And I'm like looking at my friend,
I'm like, I can't believe
they're taking that.
And they put, they hung it up on the wall
in front of me.
- Really?
- And I doubt it's still there.
They must've taken that down.
- Well, it's like the signature
that we did at AmiAmi, right?
AmiAmi is like a figurine store,
in Akihabara, it's like
one of the biggest ones.
And at one part of their store,
they have this, just these massive line
of like maybe like 50
shikishis from like artists
and like figurine sculptors
and stuff like that.
- Like proper mangakas.
- Proper mangakas
and stuff like that.
- Artists who've been there.
And we did a video then.
They were like, "Hey,
can you sign a sikishi
for us 'cause you filmed here."
And I didn't take into account,
I didn't actually think
they were gonna hang it up
next to all these amazing-
- I just think
my signature's worth nothing.
- Yeah, right.
So we were just like,
fuck it, let's just do it.
They're probably just
saying this to be nice,
let's just do it.
Turns out, I went back like a week later,
it's up there on the wall-
- Oh no.
- Next to these incredible
looking sikishis,
and it just looks like absolute dogshit.
And we're like, fuck, we should have-
- It's a macaroni art next
to like the Banksy one.
It's pretty appalling.
- I was like, fuck, it
was the first time ever,
I was like, fuck, I wish
they'd just take that down.
I don't want this clout.
- It's like that horse meme where you have
like a really professionally drawn horse,
and then the last third is
just like a kid's drawing.
that's our drawing in AmiAmi.
But every time someone goes there now,
they'll take a picture and then tag us-
- They take a picture
and they tweet it at us,
and we're like, please don't remind-
- Just the shame just gets more
every time.
- No, but I've always thought
like Japanese artists have
such amazing signatures,
and they're all good at drawing.
And so I've always felt like
that's a huge complex for me.
Like, why is everyone so
good at like autographs?
- But a signature-
- Is there a class?
- That's why I was genuinely curious.
Do you guys practice this shit?
'Cause I had to make mine up on the spot,
and that's why mine looks complete arse.
- I've never just practice or like-
- Yeah, I'm still trying
to figure that out.
- Because I feel like when we all
like first had to do signatures, right,
it kind of came out of the blue.
Like you weren't expecting it.
- I feel like a signature
shouldn't be a burden.
And when I ask a Japanese
person to do a signature,
it's like, give me 15 minutes
and a Red Bull and I'll be
done. It's like, no, no, no, no,
you can just do like some squiggles.
I don't care, just slap
it, I don't know, what.
I feel bad when they're drawings
something really delicate,
and I'm like, this is just
gonna be in my wall somewhere.
- I think at the highest pressure for me
is signing a shikishi, 'cause a shikishi,
there's a lot of white
space in those shikishi.
And there's only so many
ways I can make it look good.
So like, when I have to
throw my signature big,
it's like enlarging a
100-by-100 pixel image.
It's like Minecraft quality
that we're talking about.
It's like 360 YouTube
and it just looks bad.
- Because we're so used to doing
in like the corner of an anime poster
so that it doesn't go over it, right?
- So I, ever since I
made a debut, in Japan,
I've had to have shikishi
signatures often.
And one advice from me
is how to fill it up
is just draw a lot of stars.
- Just a lot of stars?
- Yeah, that's why
my shikishi's always filled with stars,
because I don't know what
to do with the white space.
- Yeah, but that's the problem, right?
Is that we have three people
who just cannot draw to save their life.
So it's just like-
- Same here.
- Do I like draw an anime character?
But I don't wanna get
like DeviantArt-quality
anime character next to my signature,
so it's like, what do I,
so that's why, at least with my signature,
my one saving grace was
just like the cat face.
I have to add something
to this to make it unique.
And one thing I've always found
with like Japanese artists
or like just voice actors or whoever
is that they always have
like their mark of identity.
I'm just like, what's it for me?
I'll just put a fucking cat face on it.
- I think the reason like
Japanese artists and entertainers
have sort of artwork with their signatures
is because they have to sign shikishi,
and they have to fill up that white space.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Exactly, yeah.
- Basically, just put a cat face
or make up an emoji apparently.
- Or a star or something.
- Or just lots of stars.
This is a problem that 99% of viewers
will have zero relationship with.
- Relatable topic.
- First World problem.
- So you grew up in the US
your whole life.
- Yes, exactly.
- When did you come to
Japan for the first time?
- I've been coming back to Japan,
like pretty much every year
when I was little, just-
- With your parents.
- Just to go to my
grandparents' house and stuff.
And then I went to, I came
to Japan in middle school,
and I experienced
Japanese school education
for the first time in my life.
- How was that going for an American?
- Hell.
- Hell?
But why?
- It was completely hell for me,
because even though I can speak
regular sort of everyday Japanese,
I couldn't read or write up to par.
- Am I allowed to ask this,
but why were you going to school in Japan?
Like, was there a reason why?
- Well, that's the music thing.
- Okay.
- Oh.
- I wanted to become a musician in Japan,
so I came to Japan to do music,
and I still have to go to
school, so I went to school,
but I went to regular school,
which was a huge mistake.
And I didn't go to an
international school,
you know, that kind of thing.
- How was that?
Why was it a mistake?
I'm curious.
- It's just that I couldn't keep up
with any of the education
and I was a complete loner.
So I didn't have any friends-
- I was gonna ask.
Is it hard to make friends
when you are like a transfer student?
- I think it's impossible to make friends.
- This is such a lie.
Anime would have to believe
that the transfer student-
- Yeah, they're like,
everyone is all over-
- Everyone wants to know
the transfer student.
Why would you lie to me, anime?
- It's just like, there's that one scene
where it's like a transfer
student from overseas
who's like, oh, they can speak English.
And then during the break,
they're fuckin' all over
that transfer student.
Did that happen to you at all?
- Big surprise here.
And I'm gonna give you a
huge sort of reality check,
but as anime singer,
anime is not exactly real.
- No!
- I respect your opinion, I do.
- But I'm gonna live in my anime reality.
- I will choose to-
- No, I hate to break it to
you guys, but no, no, but yeah.
- You mean you didn't sit
in like the far corner
of the classroom next to the window?
- I was actually, since I came to Japan,
and then I started the school
at a very weird time in the sort of year,
so I was like in the corner.
And so I couldn't make friends
and I couldn't keep up with
the studies and everything,
like the culture was completely-
- Right, right.
- Yeah,
it's quite different from America.
- I guess, for you as well,
it's like doubly a pressure, right?
Because you're full Japanese.
- Everyone expects me to be Japanese.
If I looked sort of American,
probably people would be like,
nihongo daijoubu desu ka?
But no, people would be
like completely normal.
They expect me to understand
completely everything.
So that was a huge source
of stress for me mentally.
- Did you, how good was your
Japanese when you moved?
- I could speak it,
but reading and writing
was completely-
- So Japanese
is technically your second language.
- Yes, it's technically my second language
and I didn't like actually
officially study Japanese in America.
- Right.
- Okay.
- And so you were in Japanese
school until high school?
- No, just for less
than two years, I think.
- 'Cause you were like, thank God-
- No, and then I just gave up
and then I went back to the States
and then I finished school there.
And then after I finished school,
I came to Japan and started my career.
- Okay, what is the Japanese
education system like compared to the US?
Because I've thought about like, if,
because I was also, I
was raised in the UK,
that was where my education system is.
I can't imagine having
an education in Asia,
'cause the culture of the
Asian education system
just seems like a lot of pressure.
And that's something that
I'm not a fan of at all.
- I think in Japan, I've only been
as a student for less than two years,
so I can't say I know
everything, but at the same time,
I think they're very, like studying base.
Everything is about
studying, studying, studying.
And it's very difficult to be
a loner in school in Japan.
You have to have your sort of niche,
and you have to have your
place and you have to friends
in order to really feel like-
- So who are like the cool
kids in Japanese schools?
Who are like the popular kids?
'Cause in, like, when I was growing up,
it would be like the people
who are good at sports
like the jocks and stuff like that.
Who is like, who are like,
what makes you popular
in Japanese schools?
I've always wondered about-
- I think it is different in Japan.
Like, it doesn't necessarily mean
like you have to be the most
fashionable or anything,
but in Japan it's more if you're outgoing
and you're also smart educationally.
- Well, that's one thing anime got right.
- I noticed there's a big difference,
because when I was growing up in the UK,
if you did well on tests,
that's like a black market.
- That's like you're bullied.
- Like, whoa, you studied for an exam?
Look at this fuckin' nerd.
- Whereas in Japan, it's
like, whoa, you study?
Oh my God, you're awesome.
- So I think that kind
of thing is different.
Like, if you're an all-rounder,
if you're good at a
lot of different things
and you're pretty much-
- The image of perfection.
You're just good
at everything.
- Like I said,
Japan loves perfection.
So I think they sort of exert perfection
in the anime as well.
Like the anime, they sort of
depict perfection in animation.
- Yeah, I don't know if,
you don't have to answer this
question if you don't want to,
but did you ever have like
any negative experiences
like bullying because
you are like foreign or-
- There wasn't exactly
like direct bullying,
but people didn't know how to
interact with me because they,
because it wasn't an international school
and they weren't exposed
to foreign people.
At the time though, now, of course,
there are a lot of foreigners in Japan,
but at the time, there were,
like if there was a foreigner
walking around in Shibuya,
people would be like-
- Yeah.
- I mean, it's still
like that in some cases.
- They didn't have an immune system
for like English and foreigners.
And so just the fact
that I came from the US
and that I was an
outsider, people were like,
oh, I don't know how
to interact with them.
Do they know the same language?
They didn't really know
how to interact with me.
So even though I was really outgoing
and I'm a people lover,
no one really wanted to sort
of interact with me directly.
They were very shy.
Japan is very shy.
So that was one of the
biggest stressors for me.
- Yeah, I definitely noticed that,
especially recently, I feel.
Even just like looking, like going out
into the town and stuff like that,
you do see like, yeah, because
like when we were in school,
I never went to a Japanese school either
because I just didn't really want to,
I heard terrible things about it.
But back then, it was like, yeah,
if you look any different at all,
because it's such a collectivist society,
you're just not gonna fit in
no matter how hard you try.
So I'm like, I'm not even
gonna bother with that shit.
But like nowadays, the other day,
I saw a bunch of high
school girls in uniform,
and among like the three
or four Japanese girls,
there was like one girl who was just
clearly African-American, like Black.
So it was like full on.
And they were just hanging out
with her like it was nothing.
In my head, I was just like, hell yeah.
Finally, finally.
Like kids actually are starting
to understand in Japan.
I'm like, you guys took your fuckin' time.
- So if I came to Japan now as a teenager
and went to school, I'd probably have
a very different experience.
- Much better.
- Yeah, definitely.
- So, you know, yeah.
- This video is sponsored by Mack Weldon.
- [Joey] Wack Weldon is a
premium men's essentials brand
that believes in smart designs
and high quality fabrics,
and offers a one-stop
shop for men's basics.
- Hell yeah, they do.
After taking a brief hiatus
from outdoor activities
and workout routines,
it's time to get back to the grind
with new spring essentials
from Mack Weldon,
with body-mapping technology
and fabric mesh zones.
- What?
- What are those?
- Well, let me tell you, Garnt.
Mack Weldon's stealth boxer briefs,
I do actually own them,
they are just in the wash,
'cause-
- Wait, is that the ones
that I'm wearing?
- Those are not the stealths,
Joey. You would know the stealths
if you actually worked out
as hard as I do because they
are so God damn comfortable.
They don't smell, they're amazing.
- They're perfect for
everyday wear or to be layered
underneath workout gear
like this smelly bastard.
And for the sweatpants,
you can wear it outside
without feeling like you're
wearing sweatpants at all.
Check out Mack Weldon's new Ace line.
- Socks, shirt, hoodies,
underwear, polos, or active shorts,
Mack Weldon promises comfort
and a consistent fit.
And it also looks great and feels great
from working out, going out,
going to work, or on a date,
Mack Weldon is for everyday life.
- With a wide range of customized
fabrics that can keep up
with you no matter what
your day looks like.
And with the Weldon Blue
totally free loyalty program,
level one gets you free shipping for life.
. Damn, that is insane.
- That's a long arse time.
And once you reach level
two by spending $200,
you get 20% off every
order for the next year.
- And don't forget about
the Mack Weldon guarantee.
- Oh God, I-
- They want you
to be comfortable, so you know what?
if you don't like your
first pair of underwear,
you can keep them and
they'll still refund you.
- So for 20% off your first order,
visit mackweldon.com/trashtaste
and enter the promo code trashtaste.
That's mackweldon.com/trashtaste
promo code trashtaste for 20% off.
Mack Weldon, reinventing men's basics.
Back to the episode.
- Okay, so I feel like it's
extra pressure as well,
because I kind of relate to that where,
I feel like if you're like
American or something,
or something that, your
blood isn't from Japan,
it would be a lot more exotic.
But because you're 100%
Japanese, coming back to Japan,
you feel like a foreigner
in your own home sometimes.
'Cause I felt like that when
I went back to Thailand.
Because people like
foreigners in Thailand,
but for me, I feel like I'm
a foreigner in Thailand,
but it's kind of like a disappointment,
because I'm 100% Thai, so they
expect me to be fully Thai
and fully fluent and fully understanding
of the culture and everything.
And when they see that I'm not,
they're just like, ah, okay,
so you're not one of us,
but you're also not cool for
being a foreigner either.
- It's like double disappointment.
- Yeah, I don't get the
advantage of being either things.
- At this time, man would
never wear a turtle neck.
What is this?
- But I can completely relate,
because I grew up in America.
But I lived on the West
Coast for most of my life.
And so there were very few Asian people.
And at the time though,
the Japanese boom wasn't existent yet.
So no one really liked Japan yet.
Everyone was like, the Asian
people were all one category.
It was like, you're
Chinese, you're Japanese,
you're the same thing.
And so I felt very like,
sort of left out in the community.
I didn't know my identity there.
And so then I came to Japan,
and then I experienced the same thing
where I didn't have an identity.
I wasn't completely Japanese.
I wasn't completely American.
And people were still not used to having
foreign people in Japan yet.
And so my timing is just
completely off my entire life.
- 'Cause like, I mean, when
I was growing up in school,
like I was, I swear, the
only guy was interested
in like any Asian culture
and it felt really weird,
'cause like, and no one gave it shit.
Everyone just cared about
like the football that was on.
Yeah, cool, cool.
But like now it's almost like,
there's almost like a fetishization
of like Japanese culture.
- Exactly.
- People love Japanese culture.
- If I grew up in the States during now,
I'd be like so popular.
- You'd be the popular kid.
- I feel like I grew up in the wrong era,
'cause like kids now find anime-
- Did somebody just say that?
- Well, because like kids
now find anime cool and shit,
and I'm just like, bruh,
where were all these kids
when I was like secretly watching anime?
- Yeah, when we were growing up,
you'd get bullied for
watching "Dragon Ball Z,"
but now, you get bullied for
only watching "Dragon Ball Z."
Like, wow, you only watch "Dragon Ball Z"?
- We can talk about this
for another two hours.
We can make another YouTube
video just for this topic.
This is an important topic.
- Yeah, honestly, because it's like,
'cause I felt that way
too like in Australia,
because I was the only kid
with any kind of Asian blood in him.
Like I don't look Asian,
but when you're in a
school that is 99.9% White,
even that 1% of Asian look
sticks out like crazy.
So, and then I had the
exact same thing over here.
I don't look Japanese at
all, so when people, fuck,
when I would say konnichiwa,
they'd fuckin' nihongo jouzu'd me,
and I'm like, it's not hard
to say konnichiwa, bruh.
Like I can say so much more.
I can say so much more,
but you don't even give me the opportunity
to give that to you.
So it was like, what the fuck do I do?
- Yeah, it's funny how time has changed,
because I remember
talking to my cousin who,
so who has a son who's
going to school now,
and he's really into sports.
He's like a super jock basically.
Kind of like-
- A super jock.
- Kind of like the opposite of me.
- A king of jock, basically.
But I remember she was telling me
about how he got bullied in school.
- For being a jock?
- No, no, yeah,
for being a jock,
because he didn't play "Fortnite."
So this-
- That's so funny. My mom was
telling me the same thing.
- So yeah, my youngest-
- Are you serious?
- Yeah, yeah, so my younger nephew,
he got bullied for not playing "Fortnite."
So one day, he decides to play "Fortnite,"
and then he still got bullied
because he had the default skin.
- Yeah, my mom works in a primary school,
like kids for like, I don't
know, age between six and 12.
She was telling me that the
kids are getting bullied
'cause they didn't have any
skins in Fortnite as well.
I was like, 'cause when I was growing up-
- Oh my God.
- When I was that age,
it was always the kid
who's the fastest who's like the coolest.
When I actually became the fastest kid,
it wasn't cool anymore.
And I was like, what the fuck?
- And then, I was always
good at video games,
I got bullied for playing video games.
But now, I would have been like,
I'd been so cool in school, man.
I was so good at video games.
- We all go through that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Chasing the trend trying to be cool.
- No, no, no, no, we're
ahead of the generation.
- Yeah, you were so fast
that you outran the trend.
- I quickly realized I'm
like, fuck everyone else.
I like what I like, and
I'm gonna do what I want.
We set the trends now.
- We're the trend now.
- I wouldn't go that far.
I'm curious, 'cause like I said earlier
about like people loving Japan now,
what do you think about people who like,
think of Japan as a utopia?
Like this kind of perfect society.
'Cause people give me shit
when I say like bad things about Japan.
Like, if you don't like it, just leave.
And I'm like, no, no,
no, I'm just British.
I just complain about everything.
- Yeah, sometimes I find
it very interesting.
Like, what is so great?
It's not that Japan has
changed so much recently.
It's just that suddenly,
it's kind of a utopia.
So I just think that Japan
is very unique, even in Asia.
There are a lot of things
that Japan does originally,
like anime and J-rock and J-pop.
And all these culture things
that Japan originally did
that is now widespread in the world.
So it's not that Japan
has changed or anything.
It's just that those little
things are being noticed.
- I guess it's just like, it's
mostly just like the more,
it's more exposure to
like over-glorification,
because now we know that Japan
does all of these like unique things
that are very different
to Western countries,
it's suddenly better, quote unquote.
You know like, yeah, of course,
like there are a lot of things
about Japan that are just more-
- I don't know what is so, I love matcha,
but I don't know what is
so heavenly about matcha.
- You like matcha?
I do, but I,
I understand that it's
good, but I don't know why-
- In America, especially,
they treat matcha like a brand of cocaine.
- Exactly.
- Japan does too.
Japan has matcha everything.
I'm pretty sure there's like
matcha toilet roll that you can eat.
- No, but what I'm saying is that-
- There's so much matcha-
- There's so many things
in America, like so many, like even-
- There's more in Japan.
- Even if it's a hint
of Asian, they're just like, yo,
we got to have matcha something.
- No, there's more matcha in Japan.
- I mean, there is-
- Yeah, of course there is
more matcha in Japan, but-
- It's too much matcha,
it's like, what's up with the-
- The way that matcha
is like marketed towards the Americans,
it's like this exotic thing.
It's a unique taste.
- Because matcha is like an
official Frappuccino taste.
- Is it?
- Like around the world, around the world.
- Oh, I didn't know that.
- 'Cause you don't get
Frappuccinos, Garnt.
I'm the only one out of the three of us
that will get a Frappuccino.
- It's 'cause you've turned more White
since you've moved to Japan.
- What it is, Garnt,
it is what it is, okay.
- I just think that globally,
the world likes green stuff.
Like wasabi, it's green.
- There's so much green stuff.
- Matcha is green.
So if it's green, it's probably-
- Puke, green, I love that.
- I love that.
- Is that what it comes-
- That's the only reason
that I can come up with.
Green tea, I mean, that's
kind of just matcha, isn't it?
- That's all matcha is, it's just tea.
It's just green, it's just green stuff.
- Honestly, I'm gonna
say, I think matcha slaps.
And I'll be the one in the
corner who will defend matcha.
- Look, look, look, don't get me wrong.
I like matcha-
- No, matcha is good.
- Matcha's good, but-
- For fuck's sake, it's always-
- It shouldn't be like,
it shouldn't be like salt.
He's just like anti-matcha, isn't he?
- Connor's just like,
finally, somewhere I belong.
Oh, no, never mind.
- But you're my side then.
- So matcha is just
the tip of the iceberg,
but there's so many things about Japan
are being discovered and
are being like utopias.
- Bidet, bidet should be-
- No, yeah, exactly.
There are a lot of things about Japan
and Japanese culture that
I think rightfully so
should be put up on a pedestal.
Like bidets, for example.
I mean, fine, you experienced a bidet,
your life has basically
changed for the better,
as we discussed in an earlier-
- Heated toilet seats.
- Japan has normalized heated toilet.
- What are some great things about Japan
that you find really like amazing?
I would like to know about that.
- Okay, for me personally,
coming from Sydney,
Sydney has one of the worst fuckin'
public transport systems in the world.
Like it's, I've discussed
it in a podcast before,
but like just having, coming
to Japan and being like, okay,
the schedule says the train's
coming at exactly 2:57.
And the fact that I can
go to the platform at 2:56
and the train arrives exactly
one minute later is like,
if if it came on time in Australia,
you'd think something was wrong.
You'd think the bus driver
had like a gun to his head,
being like, arrive here on time.
'Cause otherwise, it
just never comes on time.
- There's two sides of Japan for me,
because I love the convenience of Japan.
But there's two sides of the convenience.
'Cause there's one,
there's the daily living,
because just living in
Japan, just the daily side,
daily living side of Japan,
it's so convenient, it's so easy.
And then there's the
business side of Japan,
which is like the exact
opposite of convenience.
But like just living here,
I feel like I get the best of Japan,
because I'm self-employed,
so it's way more convenient
just to live here.
- It drives me insane like how intensely
they'll pursue politeness here.
Like, to a point where it makes
everyone's life inconvenient.
Like as Garnt's saying about business.
They'll keep people in the
chain and of the business
that shouldn't be in the chain.
Like there'll be middlemen in everything
just out of like courtesy.
And there's a point where I'm just like,
come on, this is ridiculous.
Like we can talk to you about it.
Or sounds like, no, no, you have to go
through the five middleman
who introduced each other.
- Do I really need to get approval
from the boss's boss to
just go get some lunch?
I just wanna go.
- Yeah, I mean, but I mean,
the things I love, I like the safety.
Living in London is
kind of sketch at times.
- Speaking of sketch,
you've got to talk about America, right?
- Oh, right, right, right.
- New York to Tokyo
must be like worlds apart.
And also, being from the UK,
we're not known for our
culinary excellence.
So it's nice having food that
tastes good all the time.
- And at a reasonable price.
- But I'm scared, because you know,
I was very good at
eating just like potato.
I'd be like, oh, this
is amazing, isn't it?
It's just a potato.
- Exactly, that when you come to Japan,
you become really like a gourmet.
You expect everything to taste good,
and you're like, no, no, no, no, no.
- Yeah, to me, pizza was anything
with cheese, bread, and tomato.
- Exactly, and oil.
- And I was pretty happy
with that.
- Butter.
Anything with butter,
cheese on it is good.
- And then now it's like,
this is stone-baked, right?
Oh no, oh no, oh no.
- And it's Aomori san, it's Aomori san.
- Is it locally grown?
- Which prefecture are
these strawberries from?
- Oh really?
That prefecture, embarrassing.
- Oh no, no, no, no.
- What do you mean it didn't cost $1,000
for one strawberry, get that out of here.
- Every time I go back to the UK now,
the hardest thing I have to adjust to
is just going to like, go
through like my Uber Eats
or the local restaurant
guides, like two-mile area,
and just seeing nothing
that's appealing to me.
Unless I travel all the way up
to London in the city center.
- Takeout's really good here.
Take out in the UK, it's like,
which greasy food do you want?
- It's like you get a
choice between kebab,
kebab pizza, chicken burgers.
And that's-
- I like chicken burgers,
though, I do.
- I mean, there's,
I like chicken burgers as well,
but there's a time and a
place for chicken burgers.
- What about you?
What's the best thing of both?
Like what do you like most about America?
What do you like most about Japan?
- Well, you know, the
thing I liked about America
was that it's really diverse.
You could go anywhere and
really just feel at home.
- Me too, I really like the friendliness.
- It's very friendly,
and you can have
conversations with anyone.
- It's very open.
- But in Japan,
it's hard to get friendly with people.
I think it takes time.
People are more sort of shy
and have that one wall between-
- Yeah, you feel like
you have to break down
multiple barriers to like
really get to know someone.
And even then,
it's quite hard.
- It takes time
to be able to call someone a friend.
So that's one of the differences I feel,
but there are a lot of things
I love about Japan as well.
You feel safe, you can trust
everyone, most of the time.
You can trust, and the quality is always
very high for anything, not just food,
but for any kind of service, it's great.
But I think that you get spoiled in Japan.
So once you start living
in Japan for a while
and you go overseas, like
everything feels flow,
everything feels, you know, like not-
- Sub-optimized.
- I almost understand why some people
just don't travel outside of Japan.
I'm like, why would you,
what are you gonna do?
- Things just work here.
And that's what I love about Japan.
It's just, everything you
didn't think about works,
and then except for business,
the business side, but just like I said,
everything outside of
that just perfectly work.
- I didn't realize the
London Underground was,
I mean, I knew it was dirty,
but I didn't realize it was
that dirty until you go-
- Oh, I knew that, I knew that.
- 'Cause you get like the,
you get the railway to
the airport in Japan,
it's ultra clean, you get
in your plane, you get home,
if you get the Underground to go home,
you're like, oh God,
there's shit everywhere.
- I mean, you're from New York, right?
The New York Subways are
just like another level.
- I normally feel safe
on public transport,
but the Underground,
the Subway in New York
really tested my ability to feel safe.
- Yeah, but even in the music industry,
like concert-wise, I realized
there's a huge difference.
Like when I went to San
Jose to do my first concert,
like, you know, it was
American-style concert.
So we were already used to
doing the Japanese style,
and then we went to the venue
and then it was lunchtime.
So in Japan, even if it's lunchtime,
if there's a lot of work
done, no one just strays off,
goes on their own lunch break or anything.
And everyone, like, if you have an hour,
that means you have about 30 minutes
after like clean up and everything.
But back in the States,
it was 12 o'clock, everyone disappeared,
and then no one was there.
So the Japanese team was there waiting-
- Just confused.
- Was like, oh, what do we do?
And then we're, okay, so
lunch break is one hour.
So at one o'clock, we come back
and we do rehearsals again.
So we were planning on that.
But then like the camera
people and the lighting people
like didn't appear for another hour or so.
- That sounds like an American con to me.
- But, the amazing thing is,
even though they don't like,
do all that preparation stuff,
the show, boom, they do their thing.
They do their thing.
They don't need rehearsal.
They just, boom, they do their thing.
- Oh, damn, that's, most
conventions I've been to,
there have been like
technical difficulties
on like every panel
that I've hosted.
- You got it easy.
- My flight had technical difficulty.
- That's, you know, that's
how the world works.
And Japan is just very
perfectionism in production.
- They're just like a little
too over-cautious at times,
where it's like, why are you
stressing out about this?
You don't have to have 17 rehearsals.
I think one or two is enough.
- How many rehearsals do you
have for a Japanese concert?
- It depends on the event,
but we do, definitely,
we do a lot of rehearsals beforehand.
And we'll do like, before the shows,
we go through, it's called genepro,
but it's a rehearsal where
you do it exactly like-
- So basically just a dress rehearsal.
- Yeah, the show exactly how it's done.
And you probably need to
do that two or three times.
- Bloody hell.
- So when you perform a concert,
you're not just performing it once,
you're performing it like four
times in secret most of it.
- When it's big-
- It's only the last time that counts.
- Going back, like a million topics,
going back to the, 'cause
I'm really intrigued
about the whole anime opening process.
How do you, so from
complete start to finish,
like, how do you get to like
call, where you're like,
hey, there's a show, it needs an opening.
How does that all go?
And then how does the process go?
Like, you write it, I just
wanna know everything about it.
'Cause I feel like we haven't actually
like talked about the process.
It'd be a waste not to.
- I think it depends on the artist,
but if you're signed with
an anime-based label,
then there are a lot of like
types that need artists.
So they're always looking for it.
And it depends if you are
the one that sort of offers,
or they offer for you, it
depends on the situation.
But once you sort of get an
offer or you go grab an offer,
then that sort of starts into
the songwriting creation,
and then-
- So you write all of it?
- Yeah, you have to make
it from zero usually.
So that begins there.
And I wrote all the lyrics for my songs.
Not all the melodies, but all the lyrics.
- Do they give you any
input on any of that?
Like the anime-
- Do you have like any source material?
Do you write around that, or was it just-
- Usually, we start writing
when the series isn't complete yet.
So we only get like
really brief description.
- So what was it like for
something like "BTOOOM!"?
What do they say?
- Oh, "BTOOOM!" was actually
a manga before the anime.
So that really helps.
- You just read all the manga?
- You read the manga and you
sort of, they also have hints,
like this kind of song
or that kind of song,
and then you try to fulfill
their expectations there.
But "BTOOOM!", for example,
"No Pain, No Game,"
we had a lot of freedom with that song.
So they really probably didn't
expect that kind of sort of-
- Upbeat-
- Kind of song.
But everyone really like, so it stood out,
in a good way I think, it stood out,
and they were like, wow,
we weren't expecting this in a good sense.
- I think I can speak on
behalf of the anime community
being like, most people-
- It's bangin'.
- If not all people only remember
the openings of "BTOOOM!".
- So is that like a one-take,
here's a song, I'm done,
or is it like, they constantly are always,
can you change this, can you
change this, can we try this?
- Sometimes they have very like detailed
sort of descriptions for what they want,
but sometimes, it's just completely free.
So with "BTOOOM!" though,
we had a lot of freedom,
so we didn't have to adjust
or redo a lot of things.
But for other songs, for example,
there are a couple of
retakes or recreations,
or there are some songs that
I've done, I've written,
that have completely
disappeared after it's cleared.
- So when you do an anime opening,
who owns the rights to that song?
Is it the, did the anime people
just get like a license to use it
in the anime and you retain everything?
Or like, how does that work, if you know?
- It might be the label, right?
- It's probably the label.
- I think the label
has the song.
- Yeah, you're just like,
I don't know, I make music.
- The label has the song rights.
And so when the song is used,
the rights belong to the label.
- Because I think flying DOG was like,
you can correct me if I'm wrong,
it's like a major label that was primarily
focused on like more anime music.
So a lot of anime OSTs and openings
were usually started and
owned by that record label.
So like-
- I like how you're looking at Connor
like he's gonna know what
you're talking about. (laughs)
I'm telling you because
you probably don't know.
- Fuckin' hurt.
- I'm just telling,
because I was, again, like I
was reading your Wikipedia,
and you know, flying
DOG and stuff like that.
- I did a bit of research.
- Yeah, I did,
I did a bit of research.
'Cause I was always interested
as well of like how,
I guess, like rights and
distribution works for anime songs,
because I feel it's completely different
to like an artist just
releasing their own album.
- Yeah, I always
wondered, 'cause you know,
a lot of the songs wouldn't blow up
without the anime to back of it.
So I wondered if there
was a system that like,
there's a co-ownership, or like,
I'm just pretty intrigued.
I didn't know if you knew.
- Yeah, it's very complicated.
Like the rights thing is just-
- It sounds like nightmare.
- It is a nightmare.
- I've always had issues,
like YouTube issues with like
rights and it's always a mess.
- You know in Japan, everything
about rights is huge.
You can't say certain stuff on TV.
You need permission for a lot of things.
- Yeah, we've experienced it.
- Yeah, you can imagine.
- The Japan fucking do
you have permission hell.
It's just like never ending.
- The approval chain is
just fuckin' a mile along.
- I never, like, there
were so many things,
since working with Japanese
companies that I notice.
I was like, oh, you
need approval for that?
- 'Cause it was the first time that I had,
that I experienced taking off
a label of a water bottle,
to drink it in front of media.
In America, I never
even thought about that.
- So yes, I openly drink Evian water.
- So taking the labels
off at events or like,
that is completely Japanese culture.
- I notice that the first time actually,
when I was watching
like a Japanese TV show,
and I noticed that the water bottle
on the desk or whatever
was like mosaicked out.
And I'm like, what the
fuck are they drinking?
How bad is it-
- Is this hentai water
I'm drinking, like loli water?
- What is in this water
that they have to sensor it?
- They'll show you shots on
TV, and it'd be like Shibuya,
and everything is blurred
except like two people walking.
Why are you even showing this?
They're not showing anything.
All the brands in Shibuya
and all the billboards
have to be like blurred out.
- Looks like a JAV shoot in Shibuya.
- It's odd, 'cause then two seconds later,
it'll cut to a shot
where everything's shown.
And I'm like, there's
no consistency on this.
I'm so confused.
Now there must be some rights going on
where it's completely
flip-flopping in that.
Yeah, I don't know, it's bizarre.
- How did it feel, like the
first time you watched an anime
and just heard yourself singing
before the anime started?
- Oh yeah, it was really nerve-wracking.
I was probably peeing
my pants waiting for it.
- 'Cause you're pretty much living
the dream that I think a lot of like,
especially Western weebs one,
where they're like, yeah, I can sing.
One day, I'm gonna sing
in an anime opening.
- It's very surreal, it's very surreal.
It didn't really like hit
home until a lot later.
- 'Cause do you, I assume when
you are producing the song,
you don't actually get to
see the animation opening
of like what they put to your song.
- So exactly the first time that,
well, actually, I did see
like a sample of the opening,
but the first time I actually saw
the official finalized version was on TV.
So it was probably like
the same as you guys.
I was like in front of the screen,
I was like, what the hell?
- What the hell is happening?
- I hear my voice from the TV.
- Do you normally skip anime openings?
Am I allowed-
- Um, I usually, sometimes.
But most of the time-
- Industry secret.
- Sometimes, yeah, I try to watch it.
If I like it, though,
I'll watch it definitely.
- Yeah, I mean, I don't think
there's anything wrong with
skipping anime openings.
Yeah, I said it, I fuckin' said it.
- Yeah, sometimes they're kind of mid.
- Yeah, let's be honest.
- What can you say?
- As an artist, right,
when Netflix gives you
that skip intro button,
does your heart like
die inside a little bit?
You're like, oh, not my hard work.
- I try to not imagine how
many people are skipping my-
- How dare you skip my banger song?
- Because now that you
work in the industry,
has that changed the way you kind of like
not only view anime music,
but just music in general?
'Cause like, as someone
who works in anime YouTube,
I can't look at anime YouTube as the same.
Or like I can't view it as just,
to be entertained anymore.
I can't shut off that part of my brain.
- I think it has sort of destroyed a bit
of like the enjoyment part of it.
Because everything that concerns music
right now becomes a job for me.
So I start listening to like,
it's hard to just listen to it
for my enjoyment, I do find.
- 'Cause sometimes you see someone
who does something fuckin'
great and you're just like,
damn it, I wish I did that,
I wish I could be that.
- God, I wish that was me.
Yeah, I get that every time.
I'm just like-
- Why didn't I
come up with that?
- Yeah, exactly, right?
Exactly.
- It's like,
I love this video,
except for the fact that I didn't make it.
Like, I wish I'd had made that.
- Yeah, I mean, I love you-
- I was going to do it.
But they got to it before me.
- But this person did it before me.
God damn, I hate this person,
but I fuckin' respect this person.
- They fuckin' stole the idea.
That was just in my head.
Is there like, I guess,
like very general question,
is there like a Japanese
artist that you would ever
wanna like collaborate with in the future?
- Oh, there are so many,
but especially recently,
I feel that I want to
do more collaborations.
And so you know,
like there are a lot of artists.
- I don't think we asked,
like who are some artists
that you like or respect?
- Japanese or Western.
- Japanese or Western, well, you know, I-
- Avril Lavigne, of course.
- Avril Lavigne.
Right up there at the top.
You have to live up to that.
No, but I do really respect her music,
but also like artists like Miyavi.
Oh, but one amazing thing
that happened recently,
is I collaborated on stage with FLOW.
- Oh, wow.
- So that was a real
dream come true for me.
So that was amazing because
I was a listener of theirs.
- How did that happen?
- I have no idea.
- You just turned up to
perform and Flo is right there?
- What was like, let
us introduce ourselves.
- I woke up and I was collaborating
on stage with Flo, no.
No, but it was an event,
and it was an event,
and the event side said that, hey,
it would be great if you collaborated
on a cover song with FLOW,
which was "Sanbun no
Ichi Junjou na Kanjou,"
which was a "Rurouni
Kenshin" anime opening.
So that was amazing.
But the thing is, we
met for the first time
during the only rehearsal that happened
right before the actual stage.
So that, we didn't have a lot of time
to get to know each other
more, but it was amazing.
And these kind of miracles do happen
when you're working like this.
So that's always exciting.
- And it seems like you've just,
had a lot of great opportunities
that you never kind of like aim for,
It just kind of happens.
- That definitely, I'd have to say
that a lot of the miracles that happened
were unexpected in my career.
- The next step for you though
is collaborating with Avril Lavigne.
- Ah, let's see if we can make it happen.
- So I have to ask, do
you watch any YouTubers?
- I have made a YouTube watching debut.
So I'm just a newbie right now.
So I'm starting to
search for good channels.
And I actually, I'm planning
to start my own channel as well.
I'm still studying right now.
I'm watching you guys and I'm-
- Well, I can't sing.
I do cosplay badly.
What are you gonna do
in your YouTube channel?
- Just, mostly like half of the things
I plan to do are gonna be music-based,
but half of the things are
going to be like just for fun,
just for having fun with my
watchers and me being me.
So yeah, any advice?
- Oh, that's a loaded
question right there.
- You gotta get a clickbait.
You singing, just make it sound crazy.
- Yeah.
- I sang every song ever.
- Titles and thumbnails are
like your bread and butter.
- If you don't have a catchy-
- What do you recommend then?
- Actually, I'll tell you what you can do.
Anime opening singer
reacts to anime openings.
- That could be a good-
- Tell me that's not gonna do well.
- Professional anime opening singer
reacts to anime opening.
- I'd watch that.
That would actually do really well.
That would do really well.
- Where you like break down being like,
okay, this is why this
is a good anime opening.
This is why it's a bad anime opening.
'Cause you have the
authority to say that, right,
as someone who's made
multiple anime openings.
- What else are your
favorite anime openings?
If you can say that.
- I really do enjoy like,
you know, like I said,
"Full Metal Alchemist,"
mostly like older songs,
and just, I'm a rock artist.
So I like rock-based songs a lot.
- Do you just listen to the music,
or do you pay attention
to like the actual visuals
and animation with it as well?
Or are you just like, okay,
this is a good song, I like this song?
- I think first, I'll listen to the song,
and then I'll watch the visuals,
but then I end up just
listening to the song itself.
- Yeah, that's me as well.
- I feel that's the case. It's
like, yeah, if you just like,
especially as well like
if you like a song,
at least for me, I'm like, oh,
I've never heard of this artist before.
I'm gonna delve into
everything else that they have.
And then nine times
out of 10, you realize,
hey, there's probably a reason
why they're known for this song.
- But I think, I do think
YouTube is about being real.
And so I wanna do, what
I plan to do is to show
like behind the scenes stuff
of a lot of the music industry,
like what I can, there's a
limit to what I can show,
but I will try to show some
of the down and dirty stuff
that people don't know about,
like in the recording studio,
or like behind the stage in my concerts,
and all these things.
And so I think I really
wanna just show people
what the music industry is about.
- Yeah, because what made
you want to start a YouTube?
'Cause this is very
different from the image
we talked about earlier of just like,
mysterious nano that not many people-
- It's exactly the opposite
of what I'd been doing.
- Is it just you just trying
to find something new,
trying to do something different?
- That too, but also it's just that I feel
that it's more fitting in the
generation to not be perfect.
Up until now, everything
about music was being perfect,
but in this generation, it's solely
about showing what's not perfect.
And people are more interested
in the imperfections of
the entertainment industry.
So hopefully, I can, I've
been singing for years,
and I have seen behind the scenes stuff,
so to share that with the world.
- Yeah, that'd be super interesting.
'Cause I feel that's like
a very unique position to be in as well.
Like we can't just rock up
to like a concert of yours
and being like, hey,
we're backstage right now,
this is what it looks like,
without going through leaps and hurdles
of approval and stuff like that.
- And I do feel that that's a big reason
why YouTube has grown
so large in recent years
is because people feel a
connection with YouTubers
because they see the imperfections.
They see that they're
not this perfect idol
or perfect artist that, we,
a lot of us came up from
the same background.
And then I know you did as well,
but it might be hard for
someone to like relate to that
when they don't know
all the intimate details
of your background,
where you came up from.
So yeah, it was very interesting
hearing your story today.
- Sometimes it is scary to
think that showing people
like the sort of, like
the mistakes and stuff,
the recording studio and stuff,
but at the same time, I
think that there are not
a lot of artists are
willing to show that side.
So I'm gonna throw away my pride
and try to be real with people.
Show that recording does
take a lot of effort.
There's a lot of mistakes and redos,
and it's just effort,
effort, effort after effort.
And then the CD is created.
So it's not just you
sing it, you record it,
you put it together, and fooh.
- I'd be surprised there's many people
out there who actually think that.
That it's just like, damn,
she just nails in one take every time.
- I mean, there might be
some just amazing people
who nail it in just one take,
but it's just, you know, it's real life.
So I'd love to be able to share that side
of that sort of effort with people,
how much effort does go
into making one song and one concert.
And so hopefully, people
will find that interesting.
And I might do a few weird parodies.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I'd be very interested.
- I might sing my own anime
songs with the cosplay.
- That'd be dope.
- That'd be dope as well.
- Hopefully, your channel will be ready
by the time this episode is live.
If it is, links in the description.
So when were you planning
to debut your channel?
- March 14, I think, or
March somewhere around there.
So hopefully, it'll be ready before that.
And then yeah, people can
sort of maybe click on it.
- So if a channel is up and ready,
it's gonna, you can click on the link
in the description to subscribe to nano.
And I guess that will be a
week after this episode airs.
So keep an eye for that as well.
- And I already feel
really at home right now.
So maybe I can just park here.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Maybe I can be the fourth-
- You can be one of the boys.
- It's okay.
I think we need a Trash Taste opening.
- So maybe after this time,
I'm gonna just happen
to appear every time,
like a fourth one.
- Yeah, definitely.
Well, we'd love to have
you back on sometime.
- I would love to be back.
- I think, if you're gonna be a YouTuber,
you should do our outro for us.
That's a very crucial part for a YouTuber.
- Like an outro song?
- No, no, no, no, no, outro
for the YouTube video.
You have to say it like,
like, comment, subscribe.
- Oh yeah, you gotta get used to that.
- I think-
- YouTuber coaching session right now.
Okay, so all you have to
do is look at the camera
and go, "Hope you guys enjoyed the video.
Be sure to like, comment,
and smash the like button."
You have to say smash.
You can't just say like
hit the like button.
No, it has to be like-
- You have to smash the
like, hold in the sm-,
smash the like button.
- So can I practice here?
- Go ahead.
- Everyone watching YouTube,
Thank you, that was a nano.
You have to smash
(laughs) the like button.
- I didn't expect that.
- God damn.
- Now you have to.
- Now you have to smash the like button.
- And if you're like us,
you have patrons who
are watching right now.
As seen right now.
- Look at these lovely
patrons.
- Look at all these lovely patrons.
- I think it's amazing,
thank so much, patron.
- Thank you so much, mwah.
- You're a natural at this.
- Spoken like a true YouTube.
- You're gonna be
starting drama in no time.
It's gonna be great.
- Awesome.
- Stage two, I'll help you practice
the apology video as well.
We'll go through that.
- But yeah, if you guys would
like to support the show,
then make sure to go over
to patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also, yeah, I almost
forgot our own Patreon URL.
Also, follow us on
Twitter, the sub-Reddit,
and listen to us over on Spotify.
And of course, go check
out everything about nano-
- Where can I find you?
- Where can you find me?
- Instagram, Twitter, what do you have?
- Twitter.
- Spotify?
- Twitter, Spotify,
Instagram, YouTube, yeah.
- All those links will be in
the description down below.
So make sure that you smash them.
- Smash those links too.
- Smash the like button.
- But yes, thank you very
much for coming on, nano.
- Thank you so much for having me.
I had a lot of fun.
- Very insightful.
- I don't know if what I said is any-
- It was just,
no, it was terrible.
- Yeah,
everything will be cut.
- This is gonna be a five-minute podcast.
- Your first two-minute episode.
- But it was really insightful.
Thank you so much for coming on.
- Thank you so much.
- I hope you had fun as well.
- And hopefully, I can join
you guys again sometimes?
- Yeah, definitely.
- Absolutely.
- I will definitely be going
to one of your concerts eventually.
- Thank you so much, please do come.
- When you are back performing again.
- So if you see one
loud gaijin in the back,
it's gonna probably be me.
- If you see three loud
gaijin in the back,
it's gonna be us.
- And you guys will, of
course, join me backstage.
- Of course, of course.
- And join my YouTube.
- I mean, of course,
it was implied, right?
- Of course.
- No honestly, I would love to bring,
to collaborate with you
guys on YouTube someday.
- Dude, that'll be awesome.
- I'd be more than down for that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Well, yes,
that's been this episode of Trash Taste.
Hope you guys enjoyed it and
we will see you all next time.
- Bye bye.
- Bye.
(chill music)